all right we got some new merch to tell
you about uh we got the Vintage rat tea
the hunting club hoodies and hats if you
like to get out there with that
gunpowder
as well as some new colors in the bgty
be good to yourself collection get that
and more at
theovanstore.com and uh thanks for
wrapping new tour dates to announce I
will be in Las Vegas on June 30th and
July 2nd at The Encore Theater get
pre-sale tickets with code Rat King
starting Wednesday January 11th at 10
A.M Pacific Time General on sale starts
Friday January 13th at 10 A.M Pacific
time we're also adding a sixth show in
Austin on June 8th and a fourth show in
Houston on March 23rd
um we also have a few tickets left in
Louisville Indianapolis
Shreveport Baton Rouge Boston Medford
Corpus Christi and Phoenix and New York
City get tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r that's tour
today's guest is a rare he's a rare he's
a
one of a kind and he is people say that
all the time about people
um but they're I this he is that uh he's
a comedian he's a filmmaker he has a new
special streaming on January 28th uh
live from Madison Square Garden you'll
be able to watch the live stream of it
uh we'll put that information below
um he's I saw him I saw him perform last
night it was Unreal happy to have him
here today Mr Louie CK
me
I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
I sweat more when it's cold weirdly yeah
yeah I get clammy
if I'm warm up I'm I sweat less like at
night you know
we used to have a buddy I was sitting
about sweating but it made me think
about reptiles at uh
I used to work on this farm and we had a
dude after it would rain he would go lay
on the concrete up there he'd take his
shirt off and go lay on the concrete
like really
like a reptile kind of guy because he
felt good it cools off that's like what
dogs do they sit on the Hearth you know
oh really yeah you know they sit
somewhere they find a cool spot on the
floor yeah
yeah I think it just felt good on his
skin after it would rain he would take
his shirt off
this dude named Lance and uh
he was really in touch with what made
him feel good that's a good thing yeah
that's a good point a lot of people
won't do that
but he's like I know that feels good so
I'm gonna do it
yeah that's all right yeah it is kind of
nice I think there's probably more stuff
people would do in public if they
were less probably like inhibited or
whatever about it oh definitely I was
like I was in a um let me move this a
little closer on you yeah sure I was in
uh
I think you know those places that are
like uh
it's like a chain restaurant but it's a
little better you know what I mean a
little better yeah like uh like like BJs
yeah that kind of thing yeah I forget
what it was but it was daytime and it
was really dead in there in some I don't
know Akron Ohio or some horrible place
and
um
and some big lady came in you know yeah
off the street and you could tell they
were like okay like they they have
something where they just like just let
her come in you know what I mean right
let her come in let her smell everything
yeah maybe she's got stopped at the door
one day and it got
he's like it's okay it's okay there
wasn't enough customers in there she
came in and she just started walking
through the restaurant and she takes the
creamers you know the those metal tin
creamers that are on the kind of places
uh-huh she starts drinking cream
and then she leaves
and I thought
if I wasn't worried about how that looks
I might do that yeah yeah you know what
I mean yeah like there's something about
creamers as like as a kid that's kind of
magical that's kind of cold cream maybe
she knows the time they just poured them
so they're nice and cold but if you'd
had no concern about right you might
walk by a restaurant go I bet they got
some nice cold creamers and I'm gonna
have myself some yeah yeah that's true
yeah I could see that coming through and
just kind of sniffing the cream just
having some just being always want to
like touch people on the back of their
neck yeah wow that's an interesting one
because I feel like it's like the most
kind of like it's almost like a real
parental place oh yeah it's caring it's
yeah so you you mean you're the parent I
don't know I mean maybe I would dress up
in a suit or something but I don't know
if I would be like the parent but I just
yeah sometimes I want to do that even
when I'm just talking to people I want
to like
I almost feel like if I put my hand on
the back of their neck we would know
more about each other or something yeah
you'd be closer you'd be an arm's length
away yeah when I was in school in middle
school escape that moment yeah it's hard
to escape it so then I think you're
there with like the honesty of
whatever's really going on
um when I was in Middle School if you
got in a fight they made you stand in
the hall all day and hug each other like
this no [ __ ] yeah
like what do you mean like hands on each
other's shoulders slow dance yeah yeah
you and another dude yeah yeah and
you're both going this is [ __ ] yeah
after for how long oh probably I think I
was out there for four hours one time
probably no [ __ ] yeah I mean this kid
bragcasted like blood on you from the
fight still and yeah still pretty
dirtied up I mean I will yeah he got the
best of me
but yeah we were out there and the kids
would come through during the like and
you try to be kind of cool like while it
was uh while it was like while while it
was in class you would try to like just
like be like you would kind of relax and
be cool with each other and yeah then
when the kids with the Bell would ring
and they would switch classes you'd be
like this is [ __ ] gay dude right you
know you would like but then you're
alone out there during class time yeah
so you'd have to get to know each other
so you really would talk probably right
yeah I mean would there'd be like a
period of just like man [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you man yeah but then you start going
so what what do you uh
like what are you doing after school or
where do you you know is you have
sisters right Brothers yeah oh yeah you
get into it and then he became a friend
so I like that I think yeah there's
something about that smart idea the only
that pose of hands on shoulders
it reminds me of when I was I mean that
was middle school so this was
fifth sixth grade kids boys and girls
started saying they want to be boyfriend
girlfriend you know they started to be
that thing
and it was only the cool kids that could
do that like anybody that was below you
know in the nerdy or just not popular
anybody with glasses on was out oh no
you had no currency yeah but all the
cool kids got to hook up yeah and so
they would be like Mike McDougall and
Samantha
Amanda Stebbins these real people are
gonna kiss and they and they did it as a
tribe too you didn't just walk up to
girl like I I walked up to girls and
said you want to be my girlfriend
they're like flag of the play buddy
that's not how it's done that's like
somebody coming off the sidelines and
just getting in the play hey give me the
get the [ __ ] outta come in and just sip
in your cream you know yeah yeah yeah
so you had to it would be like they'd
decide as a tribe Mike and Amanda are
gonna be a couple yeah so Amanda's
friends would push her and Mike's would
push him and they'd have to go to some
place and kiss tree or something yeah
and they would stand like that with
hands on shoulders just that exact and
they'd be like looking like trying to
look to the sides and everybody's going
come on and everything come on Mikey
[ __ ] screaming at him and he's like
and Amanda don't be a you know that just
whatever and then everybody goes oh and
it was that was weird yeah yeah they're
both queers
and one of them's stepdad was there too
like what does that do yeah yeah come on
Mike
but uh but it's a similar thing of kids
two young people trying to
your teach I never heard that that your
school must have that's a really
creative and interesting I thought it
was it was one and me and that me and
that guy are still friends I just saw
him a couple weeks ago and I thought uh
but he'll do that thing just to talk
sometimes
just once in a while it should be a
regular thing one shining mode yeah just
sing a little yeah
um I'm that it almost reminds me of Lord
of the Flies what you're talking about
because it really was I never thought
about it like that like the whole tribe
kind of had to agree that Scott and
Jessica were gonna kiss that's right and
then like if you were like like a little
[ __ ] I would stand there and kind of
like just like watch and like some
people were right up there like you know
nudging them in but some people were in
the back just yelling right you know no
things were very uh tribal of medieval
uh and there's microcosms there at those
ages oh yeah I had a friend who was very
popular
but he had me like as a side [ __ ] in
some weird way like I was his friend but
I didn't get to hang out with him in the
like we lived close to each other he
lived two houses down for me so he would
hang out with me just me and him but
when he was out with his boys like I
just wasn't invited it was a weird thing
but one time I was playing basketball
with him and some guy from his group
came over
and because he was kind of a leader
and he was telling this guy why he's out
and I hadn't seen that before like I was
just I just sat and listened and he was
like saying he was like hey man why are
you mad at me everybody's saying you're
mad at me nobody talks to me anymore
this other guy like why is nobody
talking to me and he said cuz you're
just you changed
and you're not you're not cool anymore
and he's like what do you mean I changed
I'm just being myself and he's like and
he wouldn't give him the information
like he hadn't done anything ah he's
just like you're just out man you're
just not it's not you know you should
look into yourself and decide wow what
did you do you think about it it's not
for me to tell you and the poor kid was
like crushed because this was he he was
part of this group and he was out after
that and you'd never seen him be in that
kind of stuff I've never seen that I was
fascinated by it yeah and he also did it
openly in front of me because I just
didn't count you know right
he's like this is some fly on the wall
this guy will never yeah everybody was
10 in the story I was like where the
[ __ ] did he get this sophisticated kind
of like Dick Cheney kind of like you
know
you know you're out you're out you know
[ __ ] and like your message yeah it's
literally it doesn't even matter yeah
yeah I didn't know he was yeah he'll
never make it to the Capitol to tell
anyone no I was a servant yeah I'm like
the guy who got shot in the face yeah
yeah
dude I remember uh oh what were you just
talking about oh you're talking about
friends Middle School oh yeah yeah it's
crazy when you look at a 10 year old it
looks like they're doing nothing kind of
like they're dumb and their necks
getting longer but then it's like you
look at you like um but then like you
hear a story like that and you're like
yeah they have this whole cosm and
universe that's going on well yeah cause
we don't see it when you see kids they
kind of look just Frozen face and what
because when an adult walks in the room
like in Lord of the Flies do you ever
see the movie
um oh yeah I did well it ends with just
like this boot this adult boot in the
foreground oh yeah
stops all the madness shut it down yeah
yeah but yeah you're right in their own
world they're you know
so wild to think about that because I
yeah I really get infatuated with those
kind of times man like
um
I love that kind of stuff I loved
growing up I loved like the mystery of
all of it like how everything was so
crazy and it was just
and the things you could do man we used
to um
like I remember the first time I ever
touched a girl's breasts right they had
this girl they had this dude in our
neighborhood he was Elvis impersonator
right and um like on stage or just in
life
I'll say a little more life yeah I mean
he walks around dressed like Elvis yeah
okay he walked around I mean he did his
he did as good as he could to get you
know to be there you know and uh and
anyway yeah he but he had well something
happened to him he got hit by
he's something he'd broken a leg or
something and they said it like in a
they got it set just he got it set
locally basically had like a somebody do
it so when it broke again he had like a
so he was halfway to Elvis right there
so that he started with that and he was
like hey man yeah thank you very much
yeah I just started getting into it yeah
he was just a nice guy I don't think
even Elvis got started like that
so at least you could say it was
Grassroots right so or maybe he had a
moment in the mirror where he's like
Disney because I could either walk
around like this or I could put maybe it
was a way to save it you know yeah I
think it probably saved him some Faith
because he was probably very very
embarrassed so anyway
his dog his kids he made him stay in the
yard right he had electric fence on
their yard and they were Pentecostals
and
um one of the girls let me touch her
breasts through that [ __ ] fence dude
oh and she wore a mother's nightgown I
remember she wore like a like an adult
woman wait a minute I missed the
connection who is she to the daughter
okay
and how old were you I was probably 10
or maybe 11 and she was what hmm I don't
know 40 I don't know I mean she in my
mind she was right she was an adult she
had a little it wasn't even anything
it was like a kid's breath I mean it was
a not a kid's breakfast well yes well
you were a kid you can't be a child
molester when you're a child thank you
you're welcome thank you and I want to
say that to everybody out there too yeah
all you kids out there yeah you're not
pedophiles yeah but uh oh I remember
still dude there's just so much fear
reaching through that oh yeah the the
election chain link fence no it was um
like a wire and it's not a barbed wire
pull up an electric fence Zachary if you
don't mind well yeah it's like on wood
right they're like it's like it's just a
chord yes it's like a very so you
reached your hand through the fence yeah
yeah okay there you go so there was
plenty it wasn't like you were touching
fence no but it was so and he came up to
the fence yeah wearing in her mother's
nightgown I I swear to God it was a yes
it was an adult to me it seemed maybe so
adult also too I just want a little
context okay like before and after yeah
because when I'm picturing with this
this picture that you're showing of like
this fence in his field which is where
electric fences are usually in a
desolate place right they don't this was
I was just picturing this girl with like
wind flapping around this thing and then
you just come and then you just do this
this was like the way you get you know
like it's scanning your hands so you can
get into the into the uh chamber yeah
but I mean I wasn't like did you make a
plan or did you see her across did you
see her across the fence and go hi Becky
and then you came to talk and then she
said would you like to touch my breasts
was it like that I knew she liked me
okay I knew that they couldn't get out
like their Daya did not let like they
didn't have a babysitter so they would
just lock the gate or whatever right
this is the kind of those times yeah and
so those times for some people oh yeah I
don't know I mean it was like Yeah in
our area I think if you had a gate that
was your step that was like your dad
okay you know for a lot of people yeah
just like that yeah so but I remember
yeah I got close and just
yeah she knew I liked her and I guess I
think she'd been a little bit somebody
had
she had dated I think she'd been on a
date okay so she had maybe a little more
exp you know I felt like [ __ ] yeah that
was at that age there was that thing
where some of us had done it and some of
us hadn't yeah
oh and it was such a oh when we heard
that there was a summer where somebody
like
You Got a Boner like got a sex on a pool
toy or something holy [ __ ] and people
were losing their [ __ ] yeah the kid who
uh got rejected by my friend
he went he got went rogue you know he
became a uh like a a bit of a nut so
then we were all in middle school or
about to be in middle school he started
doing some drugs and stuff and he would
uh at Halloween I remember he would wait
till the end of the night and [ __ ]
take kids candy like he would take full
sex he would just walk up to kids and
just grab and get the [ __ ] away from me
and he would just he didn't even like
the candy
he was really [ __ ] up but I found him
I I went I sort of latched myself to him
like I went from that other friend I'm
like this is the guy I mean this is
somebody worth knowing now
but he was the first kid I knew who had
like a [ __ ] ton of porn and stuff and so
yeah and he was the first person I
talked about sex with
and he was like I wanna someday I gotta
[ __ ] a woman so you know so then I heard
that he [ __ ] a girl oh wow and I
remember I I saw him in a park and I'd
heard that he [ __ ] a girl and I ran to
him yes yeah yeah and I said hey man I
heard you [ __ ] a girl and he said calm
down man
calm down
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about just shut up and I
realized he's on the other side of this
line that I'm I'm a child and he's a man
yeah and he wanted nothing to do with me
anymore so [ __ ] yeah it was tough yeah
there's that line there's that like
moment you cross over yeah I remember
finding some pornography in my brother's
closet and
and I found some liquor at the same time
right and so I was having liquor and
looking at uh pornography and I blacked
out I couldn't handle it
I [ __ ] blacked out and fell off the
shelving unit and it wasn't from the
liquor maybe you just couldn't you just
overloaded yeah I had two I'd had two
sips of it it was Peach but I don't
think it was anything I couldn't handle
yeah it was too much at the beginning oh
there was like so too much I remember
the first girl that I had a specific
sexual feeling about was this girl in
junior high school we called it Junior
High School where I grew up yeah yeah
and uh she I had this fantasy about her
I would lay in my bed just before I did
anything to myself or anything I just
lay in bed and think about her oh yeah
and I would picture her she wore this
because I always saw her gym class it
was this yellow t-shirt and a and blue
shorts was the UniFi where uniform with
Jim oh wow and uh and I just would
picture her just lifting her t-shirt
just a little bit
and that was and I go stop there like I
don't I would tell myself don't ever in
your life
think past that point it's all past that
is not okay wow and I stayed there for a
long time
did you um oh I remember at summer camp
they had this cute girl right I think
she was cute I don't know she was a
female
and she would let us come over and look
she had like this kind of boyfriend that
liked her and we're all kind of jealous
as other camp counselor yeah and
sometimes she would let us come over and
look down her shirt and oh yeah and he
would sit there right by kind of like oh
a little bit of a cuck thing a little
like monitoring like you're allowed to
come in and see what's in the shop you
know whoa he was a counselor yeah were
you a counselor were they all Council I
was a kid wait a minute so he was a
counselor was she a counselor she was a
counselor yes oh yeah she was a
counselor yeah oh so it was like we're
gonna let the boys look at her tits yeah
I think it was just I don't know if it
might have been raining out or something
there wasn't like anything planned or
whatever but hey
I remember they that we got to go over
and like and one kid I remember this
crazy dude yeah this black kid tried to
put his hand oh really sure yeah what'd
they do what did the guys do the guy
kind of shut him down okay that's what
he was there for and then yeah and I was
like oh this kid knows more than I do
right because I was like I went up hands
behind my back like I was oh you did oh
man I was like because I feel like if my
hand I can't control my hands around a
tit so I gotta put on back there that's
enough control it just gave me a little
bit of leeway a little bit Yeah if I
felt him coming across my hip walk away
yeah yeah yeah yeah I get it I'm I'd
like to imagine the conversation between
those two counselors you know
what are we going to do today Checkers
what are we going to do it's raining and
then she's like how about we let him see
my tits and he's like well I don't know
I'll be okay if I'm in the room I think
that's okay yeah
that's wild yeah it was just but it's a
crazy house hell like moments were so
I don't know there was nothing stronger
in the world to me than some of those
moments of being in a child especially
when like sexualization came into things
just a giant I mean I was first I had a
really slow build because
I wasn't like in the popular group
so I didn't kiss a girl
in middle school once I didn't kiss a
girl till high school until sophomore
year in high school that's kind of
normal I think I guess maybe it is yeah
but you had the good looking friend that
would kiss girls oh yeah there was a
couple I remember
um
this guy Mike walking with him once from
school week we could leave go out for
lunch and stuff at our high school and
he was uh he took a shirt off his
Summers who's just walking in in shorts
or something and girls were cat calling
him and I had never I'd never heard of
that
of girls they're going oh Mike you know
come on baby give it to me and he'd go
like no no not for you he was like kind
of coy yeah and I never knew that girls
like lusted after guys I just thought
it's guys want sex and women you know
girls let you when they give you when
they want to let you for some other
reason or something like that yeah
because I hadn't still hadn't done
anything and then when I was a sophomore
um I met a girl I think well there was a
girl that I went on a date with who I
just fell in love with and we kissed and
we fell in love and then she lost
interest immediately so she I got
heartbroken right away but we only ever
kissed but this girl Becky was the first
girl that she was like let me touch her
tits oh let me put my hand in her jeans
whoa it was like all at once with Becky
just those two
because the early things are all things
you do for them yeah I mean the idea
they're going to touch your dick is like
that that's oh that was crazy never
gonna happen no first the first like
three bases are all [ __ ] you do for them
really yeah and my dick my penis hurts
so much I've been touching it so much it
was always in pain
I was like self-abuse oh dude it was too
much yeah like if I owned if I treated
anything as bad as I treated my penis it
would be unbelievable imagine you get a
little guy around and you just beat him
on the back all the time until they spit
up
and it feels really good when he spits
you're like yeah
it would be hard not to beat the [ __ ]
out of that kid every day every day I
would hire other people to come beat him
the NFL playoff picture is locked in and
my go-to place for Wild Card round
action is DraftKings sports book it's an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL
to kick off the road to the Super Bowl
57 new customers can bet just five
dollars and get 200 dollars in free bets
instantly if you don't have an issue
with gambling then I think this is the
place to do it plus all new and existing
customers can get a no sweat bet each
day of the Wild Card round this weekend
just place any NFL bet of your choice
and if it loses you'll get a free BET
back up to ten dollars action's so good
why bet NFL playoffs anywhere else
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code Theo new customers can bet
five dollars on the NFL and get 200 in
free bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with code
t-h-e-o minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details do you hope to grow your
e-commerce business in the new year
you may be selling um pool toys you may
be selling wristlets if somebody likes
something on their wrist you know some
people they show their wrists they want
they don't want a naked wrist I
understand it
but if you're selling anything
then you might face some e-commerce
challenges in the coming year especially
after the holidays with people returning
things and things don't fit you know
well I ordered you know I ordered a
bikini and this is a damn uh uh a onesie
you know
ship station can help you figure all of
this out
that's right ship station helps you get
through things faster whether you run a
side hustle or a giant Warehouse keep
customers happy and fulfill more orders
than ever all while cutting shipping
costs and managing it all from a single
dashboard
and they have the best rates in the
industry which just got even better with
up to 86 percent off USPS and UPS rates
it's not a question of if you should
switch to ship station but why you
haven't already make the New Year the
best year and grow your business with
ship station use promo code Theo today
at shipstation.com to sign up for your
free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com use promo code
t-h-e-o if you're starting a side
Hustler if you have a big business
shipping is you don't want it to be hard
you want it to be easy ship station make
ship happen
yeah no it really is crazy that poor I
feel for little boys because it's like
you're a boy you don't know how to
handle yourself you don't know how to
keep your room clean
you know a little boys just they smell
they don't they don't they're animals
yeah and then you learn that there's
this thing that makes you calm and it's
like forget it you'll rip it off um
you'll rip it straight off your body
like you get as close as you can oh yeah
no you get you get to the point where
like I can't do it anymore like I I need
like a week off
because it stings I can't get here yeah
oh I want to rip it off and throw it
back to Africa sometimes
like that's really how I feel man sure
and somebody they'll make a [ __ ] soup
out of you know I'm saying they don't
even it's like that's what they'll do or
I think wait for white dicks to land
there's another one there's another kid
who couldn't take it and they make a
soup throw it back to the motherland
yeah I love stuff like that man those
feelings all that stuff did you um have
like a role model telling you about sex
or anything growing up uh
no I had friends and all of us I
remember when we my friends and I first
started like the group of friends that I
had would talk about sex
and the one and we're like telling each
other how it works
and one kid said well you put your penis
in her vagina and you just and you and
you come he said that you come one of
your balls comes out when you come oh
and it really hurts oh yeah and I said
and we had had sex ed in school I said I
don't know if you guys paid attention
but that's not what happens
I said first of all you go in and out
and they all my friends were like you
[ __ ] idiot no you don't you just put
it in you don't go in and out like
somebody got loitering at a heart
like the door
no you you just go he's just like you
just leave it in there
but uh no my father taught me my
father's odd guy and uh he sat me down
and he said uh I think my mother told me
need to talk to him oh I had three older
sisters that was the only boy
so she said you need to talk to him
and what he told me was
he said when you have sex with a woman
you need to make her desire
you
so you enter her he just skipped all the
like how it works he just said you enter
her a little bit you touch just barely
touch her
and then you come out and you and you
withhold he was Mexican and he had a
weird sort of traditional
he'd say and then you and then you make
her beg and beg and then you go in again
and you go only a little bit and then
you just come out again and you you keep
withholding and until she can't stand it
and only then do you really penetrate
her and she'll
come like a rocket like he was just he
taught me how to make a woman come he
wasn't wrong right he wasn't wrong but I
think you need to tell a little kid some
other [ __ ] first
before you get to like how to make a
middle-aged woman come yeah yeah you
know what I mean yeah but that's what he
was like he was very narcissistic and
you know wow yeah I uh who taught you
it's about sex I mean did you have I'm
asking the same question a mentor yeah
thanks for asking man my dad well my dad
was 70 when I was born so my dad was an
older guy yeah and so he um
he would always tell me he had dated
chicks grandmothers that were like in my
class and stuff like that and he would
show me like poems that he had written
and they were like on paper that was
like disintegrating like it was like it
was also he was teaching you about
romance yeah my dad was more of a
romancer that's nice
so he was teaching about romance but
nothing about sex one time I saw him
he I think he had cancer somebody was
walking down the hall and like
I thought he was going to have like he'd
had a new girlfriend and we were at her
house she had a nice house and she made
all this like beef brisket or whatever
I'd never even seen it you know blew my
[ __ ] mind yeah just what what your
were your parents married they were
married till I was seven and then they
got divorced and did he have kids before
with other women yeah okay he had three
other children okay so he's now so now
you're how old I'm maybe at this point I
was probably 12 and you saw him
somewhere and he had another girlfriend
yeah
you'd only ever had baloney and call it
concerns oh I've never had brisket no of
course not I mean I was
yeah never even I never even couldn't
imagined it and then um
I he was walking down the hall and I
thought he was going to like have sex
videos at night time and I would sleep
on their living room on the living room
couch and then he literally uh
he was sick and he defecated all over
himself and it was like one of the
scariest again craziest things that ever
happened because I remember watching him
and thinking well
my dad's going uh
like be with this lady you know and she
was like wealthy and I don't even know
why she even liked us but she did and
then he was sick you know and then I was
so afraid to try to go to help or
anything because he was like
he had cancer and he was getting real
sick I didn't know wow but it was that
anyway that story took kind of weird
term but yeah dude that's just life you
know but yeah it was like a moment where
there was just a lot of life but so uh
one interesting way you put it is you
say what she didn't know why she liked
us so you and your dad were like a unit
you were like a team like so did when he
left when your mom when your mom and him
divorce he went with Dad no I stayed
with my mom but I always felt like my
dad was just more loving yeah my mom has
like kind of like an emotional kind of
autism like she can't show you affection
kind of that's hard yeah and um a lot of
parents like that it's hard is there
yeah yeah
so it was just kind of like but she's a
hard worker and stuff but anyway it was
uh so then and I was kind of infatuated
by my dad because nothing he did he was
older so everything was awful little it
didn't make sense
um and it was kind of I think it was
more fascinating you know being around
him yeah I felt that way about my dad a
little bit because he wasn't like any of
my friend's dads he was a strange guy
who's a Mexican and um
yeah it was a bit like you European
Mexican you know there's a lot of
different kinds of Mexicans
um I lived there until I was about seven
oh nice um but uh but yeah he was weird
so I kind of like I was fascinated by
him but I he didn't show much interest
he I just remember him always looking at
his eye level like he didn't look down
at me much I just always looked up at
his face and he was looking that way
wow what is that do to you well it's uh
hard
but I feel more bad for him because he
didn't he was alone up there I didn't
think about that I do now because he's
you know very very old and in a chair
like this and he's alone no you know we
don't go see him much me and my sisters
yeah and my mom I mean when she was she
died and in her last year of life when
she was you know we were like there and
kept her in our houses and kept took
care of her until the last second she
had us all around her never alone
because she just was a a loving person
and she you know you wanted to be with
her oh wow but my dad was all [ __ ] up
in his own head and he was you know I
mean narcissism is like a it's a
sickness yeah and it's isolating and
it's very sad you know I feel bad for
him now I'm able to feel bad for him
because he was um it was painful to be
his kid you know physically and mentally
so
um but I'm past that 55 years it takes a
long time to you know were you surprised
how long it took to get past that kind
of stuff because I find it's interesting
a lot of audiences like kind of guys
that kind of like are fit still figuring
things out it's kind of like a lot of
late bloomers yeah I think and no
judgment to any of the listeners but
um yeah I think a lot of young men are
stuck in this time where it's like yeah
we're fake it's almost like you're
figuring sheer it out your parents [ __ ]
out it's like it's almost come to like
this kind of like curve in the pipe
where it's like we gotta kind of figure
this [ __ ] out in here yeah I think
that's right and I think uh it's hard I
don't think you can rush it I don't
think I think it happens later because
something comes loose it just does it's
nothing you can figure out it's nothing
where you can go oh I mean you think
about it once in a while some and also
you spend a lot of Life avoiding it
right so like my when I was a young dad
and stuff I just pushed my dad away I
just didn't want to think about him so I
just decided he doesn't matter anymore
for years and like when I was little I
remember he was spanking me once which
is now to me a really odd thing is a
man's hand spanking that [ __ ] bare
ass a little bony I can't fathom it now
yeah put pants
what are you doing it's really gay and
weird and upsetting yeah but uh I
remember being spanked so [ __ ] hard
like was it was like blackout spent like
I can't handle this and I remember
thinking to myself I think I was about
nine I thought the day I get a wallet
like that was the magical thing the day
I get a wallet with that money in it and
cards and that set of keys the second I
have that I ain't never gonna look at
this person again in my life I'm getting
away from this guy as soon as I have
those that's all you need
so you had a lot you were really you
were it really yeah I really didn't like
being around him and my mother divorced
him when they were when I was 10 so then
I had a lot of years just with Mom where
he was around and he would ask for
attention sometimes and I didn't I
wasn't afraid of him anymore but I but
he made me uncomfortable I didn't like
being around there's a lot of good
things about my dad and I I owe him a
lot
um yeah totally you know and he hated
you he did and he also devoted a lot of
life to you know he was a Mexican and he
his our family Mexico they do okay and
they have some influence and they have
you know he had a better life there but
he moved to America it's sort of the
opposite of most immigrants that he went
from Mexico where he was pretty well
established to America where he had no
tools to survive and where he didn't get
the culture but he did it because my mom
was the strong one in the family my mom
worked really hard and she she raised us
and and supported us so uh so he he is
picking my mom instead of somebody in
Mexico and that's how I got to be in in
the land of opportunity yeah it's
interesting yeah it's interesting man
how they have a lot of times it's our a
previous generation had to kind of take
an L they had to like really that's
right so you could have it you know it's
hard to imagine imagine that in your own
life I'm gonna do something shitty yeah
oh I'm gonna move to Toledo so my son
yeah [ __ ] you kid good good luck I'm
gonna do something I'm gonna go to Vegas
and just keep trying to win yeah I'd
rather sell my ass on the internet yeah
[ __ ] that take my chances but I I then I
so I went through years of like not
wanting to think about them and then I
once in a while I would check in with
him and see maybe we have something and
he'd feel the same and like I don't want
it and he didn't even seem interested
sometimes and that was shitty
um but then and my mom meanwhile took
care of him she after they divorced she
kept because he was kind of a mess and I
learned from that from watching my mom
do all the way to the end you know my
mom when she was dying she provided for
him and stuff and I learned about her
from that and I asked her about it
because because she had no reason to be
with the guy anymore they had been
divorced since I was 10 and now you know
this was a few years ago
and she said I want to send a message to
him with she's leaving him some money
she said that he's I want to send him a
message that he's not alone in the world
now that I'm gone
somebody gives a [ __ ] about him
and because that's a that's a promise
she made him when she married him and
even though they divorced she's she's
still honored that promise even though
he didn't stay to his side or whatever
and so that helped me like I was a that
was a
that was a role model for me my mom
later in life and then after she died I
was about to say left uh after she had
left
after she left me by ceasing to breathe
that's great and some guys probably
think that yeah [ __ ] you Mom yeah I
needed you [ __ ] after she died my
sister and I who were were at her uh
Memorial we had for her and he came and
neither of us had seen him for a long
time and we were talking we were
standing in a room talking about we we
should uh
um where are we gonna put him so we
don't have to be near him and then he
walked up with a cane and we're both
like [ __ ]
come here and we sat with them and then
we had this interesting affection for
him because Mom is gone she would have
wanted us to be good to him and he was
so weak
and he was so and I just felt bad for
him and I felt a tenderness for him so I
go to see him once in a while in this
place where he lives and last time I saw
him I just let I let go of everything it
just all went away and now I just feel
this tenderness but I just feel so sorry
sorry for the guy
I'm all that's left all anger and guilt
all those bad feelings they burn away
with time they all burn away completely
and so I'm just left with who's I sort
of fascinated by him now I look at when
he talked he struggles to talk and I
look at his face and watch it struggle
you know and I feel I feel for him you
know anyway long answer sorry but no but
it's kind of a beautiful answer it's
about how life is you know it's like
it's funny when you go back to see like
kind of the Dragon whatever the dragon
is and the time has affected it and it's
changed yeah it's all time it's gonna I
mean for your listeners that are
struggle with it it's like you can rush
it and and it's okay if you have blocks
and stuff you'll you'll I mean you can
trust yourself a little bit you know
what I mean you'll get there you'll get
there when it's time
yeah I think uh I I have I had a lot of
like I was ashamed of my dad a lot I
think because of his age and so I think
I had for a while I had some issues with
that but even over time that kind of
went away you notice how I would kind of
like
probably look at him or I would
introduce him to people as my
grandfather just little things that it's
like
you know I start to think well I wonder
how that affected him or
um I don't know
it's interesting man I'll I'll just love
all that kind of stuff like how people
relate to one another and and especially
from our parents growing up did you wish
you had a dead like other kids dads that
were like younger and stronger and more
dad like Dad like or a little bit but
then like some one dude you know his dad
like held up the ready-made with a
shotgun for pills you know so it was
like my dad just like bought a my dad
bought a Cutlass like a Delta 88
remember those cars yeah sure I remember
them well yeah and pull one up wrong car
yeah it was uh oh yeah well he had a
long kind of rectangular car wasn't it
well yeah some of the early ones were he
had a good LTD too for a while
yeah those were [ __ ] they just that
hood oh you you could just live on that
book it was so warm in there they're
always like four cats in there yeah sure
and they would stay in while we drove
somewhere like it was like
it was those parts floated too man they
were comfortable oh yeah I loved cars
like that oh I feel like you get yeah
six blocks and you're pregnant in that
[ __ ] yeah that was a dad car when I was
a kid but then when I was in high school
everybody would have those like kids
would have those and they'd spray paint
them whatever you know with cans of
spray paint yeah yeah and they were like
badass [ __ ] cars I mean the bumper is
like this thick and it's pure steel it
was [ __ ] it was like make it made of
iron in that car oh they were so good
about three miles to the gallon my dad
bought his off a couple like brothers
that lived around the corner in our
neighborhood and so it had like these
big speakers in it right and so he would
drive and he couldn't even hear right
they had like 22s in the trunk and so he
would be listening to like Paul Harvey
and like uh whatever that is NPR or
something it was with NPR within or
maybe it's just Paul Harvey what is that
I don't even know who that is uh good
day remember that guy on the radio oh
yeah yeah okay Rush Limbaugh right oh he
listened to Russia okay Russian about
NPR are very different oh they are so he
would listen to Rush Limbaugh or those
guys and then it would be like uh but it
would be with bass right like so he
would just be driving around talking
about listening to like insane like with
a real bottom to it it was unbelievable
and he always had like this old his car
was just stacked with just [ __ ]
because he my dad got this job like
going to like he would go to college and
sign people up for credit cards like
that guy or whatever oh
and that was one of the first place he
would take me there with him when I was
like 11 or 12 he even let me drive him
because he was [ __ ] like you know at
that point he's 82. so uh so as soon as
I was about like five maybe
6 or 70 let me drive him over there and
then I would stand on the table and like
bark at people to come over and get the
credit card thing yeah and I think maybe
that's where someone like my first
semblance of like getting on stage or
like saying stuff or whatever kind of
came from
um but yeah that kind of stuff man I
love thinking about growing up and what
happened and how it affects us now
um
we had uh it was one other little story
I was gonna tell you
let me see if I can think of her for one
second dad and the shot guy was held up
a store with a shotgun oh yeah dude
the other parental role models in our
neighborhood it was pretty bad I
wouldn't have traded my dad for other
dads I wouldn't have yeah I did like
that I do feel lucky that I had a weird
dad then I had an unusual father
uh my mom used to say that he's not
boring you know and it makes you who you
are I mean you're from a you have a very
specific background in a very very you
know a very rare upbringing and that's a
great thing for you now right right yeah
at the time it felt painful but now I
realize wow this was all uh part of the
plan that's right
um we had that now I did admire like
that Magnum PI dad with the [ __ ] like
I mean just the hair coming up around
the bottom of the shorts yeah like the
hair was like trying to get back up to
his mustache you know it was like yeah
this hair has a plan that's right
[ __ ] dude and we had to go out there
and push this one dude Glenn his dad had
that big uh dish that DirecTV dish oh
yeah sure we had to push that [ __ ] to
get the porn so we'd have to go out
there you'd earn it you know oh yeah
yeah yeah and we'd have to get that
Cinemax and we'd [ __ ] Put Your
Shoulder into it or you couldn't come
that's right I remember that the Cinemax
and that stuff that I remember Holton
box office HBO was the first thing
and I mean I don't know how old are you
again I'm 42. okay so I'm 55. and I
remember first there was just television
I don't know you probably don't go back
that far it was just terrestrial I mean
there was just Dan tennis and Tennis
yeah and uh no TV got really good
reception no TV on the in the world
really got a reliable picture I mean
that's the way I remember it it was just
always maybe some rich people but you're
still beholden to weather you know
phones didn't sound so good like
everything was a little wonky
and um
the channels were you know
whatever different cities was usually
like two four five and so it was like uh
ABC CBS and NBC right and then Fox came
along and it was like that's interesting
and then you have this UHF channels
which was this other dial you'd put the
your your dial it just has seven numbers
on you and UHF we had like 50 channels
that were a different frequency and
those were local stations that had like
like movie like a lot of them showed the
local sports would be there right uh in
Boston it was channel 38 was the Red Sox
and then they had movie loft where
they'd show old movies so that's where
you could see stuff like that with
thousands of commercials and stuff right
but then HBO came along and it was a box
that you put on top of your television
box office yes home box office and also
the idea of like a box office like
you're going to a movie and uh and it
had an antenna I think and it had an it
but it scrambled and it brought in a HBO
is a scrambled Channel and this thing
was the decoder I think it was still by
antenna at first
and they had like dirty movies violent
movies wow stand-up comedy with cursing
yeah and boxing and it was [ __ ]
incredible and then another company
called star case came along and they
were competitors but they both and then
they then they had a cable then it was
like we'll bring it to you in a cable
and then cable TV was like everything
coming in on this crazy cable hundreds
of channels and all that stuff all at
once but
but that was that thing that HBO did was
like you know we're you could see
anything here that changed the game yeah
because you otherwise you wait till the
movie comes through town right there
wasn't you know and around then V then
VCRs started up and then you could get
it you know those cassettes and uh yeah
we had VHS as I remember big you know we
had to ride our bike to go get it and
they had that porn room remember the
room sure yeah I worked at a video store
oh you did when I was a kid when I was
in high school wow so I got a little
overly too quickly exposed like I mean
we had a porn room oh and I would the
guy that owned the store was just he
just gave me the keys like he made me
run the store oh my God so yeah after I
would wait I would like look at the
clock waiting for it like
I just wanted to close so I could always
go in the back room in his office and
just [ __ ] just jizz oh everywhere I
would have [ __ ] licked the boxes I
think yeah it was real it was a lot oh I
remember seeing some but one guy
chiseled some tits into a [ __ ] tree
in our neighborhood right like in these
woods behind our fence
and see what had chiseled a [ __ ]
setup oh bangers homie some [ __ ] milk
muffins Daddy he [ __ ] chiseled a pear
we think you mean like an artist like he
he yeah or like a I don't know what it's
called what's that chisel with a little
flat head on it
uh yeah I don't know what his tools were
or whatever but this guy was pretty good
I would say probably and then but people
would go out there and come you know
[ __ ] oh you'd see there was porn
magazines back there and it was on this
little Hill kind of so it almost had
this that's incredible native or think
people I think people said it was Native
American or something but I don't know
but you didn't you knew the guy that did
it though oh yeah
oh yeah amazing dude I'll tell you
another story about the same guy so
he one time me and my buddies this kid
some are all were walking on the street
and it but it was a tree though so it
was like a living tree yeah and there
was tits on it that he chiseled and not
I mean if folks would come and jack off
to it yeah I don't know how many folks
yeah I mean it wasn't like people were
like buses wouldn't say yeah it wasn't
like yeah what do you call it but a
Graceland or something yeah yeah
but if you knew you knew you know what
I'm saying like
um and this was also woods and people
used to go to the woods to jerk off huh
and that was something you'd find I
think in any town you hear people
there's pornography in the woods it used
to be people would bury a Stacks I found
a stack of porn that's in the woods that
was first thing I first time I ever saw
any of that yeah and we had they had an
empty broken washing machine right there
and people would put the porn in there
right and so uh you get to you know get
your [ __ ] you know get that deal out and
then now the first porn I ever jerked
off to was some girl or tits in shorts
and she had gra gravel all over it
because because I found it in the dirt
oh yeah just like pock marks from the
gravel
life is sad buddy yeah but it's real
dude God and look In some cultures you
still find that you know so go ahead I
don't mean interrupt you so what no that
was it there would be you know you would
ejaculate to that and uh but it was a
different yeah people would go into the
woods it's almost like
you know you'd Bring It Back To Nature
I mean my dad I remember caught us
jerking off one time and made us bury it
in the yard bury the semen in the yard
well to make it like
um
respectful or something yeah
but you would just you wait a minute how
did he he caught wait first he said he
caught us jerking off yeah yeah well I
guess it was there was uh it was just me
but I say us I don't feel alone I think
I do that a lot sure that makes sense
but so he walked in and you would you
would just come on yourself yeah well my
mother caught me
and then she so she went to him and said
he's been jerking off she told him yeah
she would always kind of rat me out
about stuff like yeah but was the chiz
doesn't stay like how did he no but he
just said wherever this is you need to
take it and put it in the yard and that
was it so he just kind of went like that
oh it was on a sheet oh it was on a
sheet okay so the thing you came on yeah
had to be buried
it made me create a respect for him I
think like as a and it gave me a kind of
a
uh affinity for nature
sure you [ __ ] nature in a sense
oh dude I remember my buddy would come
over and we would just [ __ ] Mount our
pillows yeah different corners of the
room yeah when your teenage or preteen
boys when they start pre-teen yeah there
is there is like uh camaraderie in that
stuff yeah I had a friend who used to we
used to tell each other stories about
girls like I I'd sleep over his house
and he'd sleep on his bed I'd sleep on
the floor
and we called it telling each other
juicers that's what we called it juicer
so like he would tell me he'd say you
know pick a girl and I'd say you know
Gretchen yeah and he'd say okay so you
you and Gretchen are in school and you
know you're like you decide to walk home
together and go to her house and you
just walk me through this story
that's good and then I do it for him
with whatever girl he wanted oh I can't
even imagine y'all did that for each
other yeah we did it was yeah and I
don't think
that's awesome I don't know if we were
coming yet
I think it was just about squeezing it
and getting this like getting this
feeling and just listening to what he's
saying and just it didn't occur to us
that I mean we're talking about girls we
didn't feel weird about it we we're good
friends you know I I liked him he was a
good kid and it sounds like it yeah he
was you know it's something you do for a
buddy dude if I laid on a bunk bed right
now and another man laid on the floor
and told me uh took me through like a
good story I'd probably appreciate it
it's so much more real than having to
just jerk off to something you see on a
screen yeah that's no good I think
that's one of the things right yeah I
think
dude I remember when I first got an
erection I thought it was poop coming
out of the whoa front
and I remember being so scared
and um and I told this teacher and
I then I think the teacher might have
been like a gay man and so then I got
this totally weird reaction from him
but I remember thinking that poop was
coming out of my
like getting gotten lost whoa and that's
what the erection was that's a
terrifying thought oh dude
because then I was afraid to go pee
because I was like it's gonna smell bad
oh my God and that's terrifying oh you
know I'm on it look at my wig baby I'm
wigged up and wigged out I'm wigging
that's right
keeps
keeps help you keep your hair two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they are 35 years
old that's unbelievable
but it's what's happening
look at some people some of them don't
have no hair
and that's hectic baby
that's really hectic if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss
go to keps.com
t-h-e-o to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to receive
your first month free
that's right each treatment plan comes
with a full year of unlimited messaging
so you can connect with your medical
provider about anything at any time
remember prevention is key when it comes
to hair loss treatments can take four to
six months to see results so act fast
I'm feeling mine come back in I'm
hitting strong I'm topping out
I got a dang Garden baby I'm sure
cropping
to keep your hair
go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free you
know starting off the new year with uh
some attainable goals is what I try to
do I want something attainable I want to
drink more water
I want to budget better
you know I want to set aside some time
where if I want to have a candy I'm
gonna have a candy
I'm not gonna feel bad
I'm not gonna you know whine about her
or uh or threaten anybody because I'm
angry at myself I'm just gonna have a
candy you can do it
the beginning of the year sets the tone
for the rest of the year
and if one of your goals this year is to
take control of your credit card debt
now is the time to start
you can use what I've used light stream
they pay off your credit cards faster
with a low fixed rate loan a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream can
help you pay off your credit cards and
lock in a low fixed interest rate
I think that's key if you have one
that's at 24 and one that's at 17 you
got to get out of that lock them all in
rates start at 7.99 APR with auto pay
and excellent credit plus the rate is
fixed so it will never go up
over the life of the loan and that is
what is magical from lightstream you can
get a loan from five thousand to one
hundred thousand there are absolutely no
fees you can even get your money as soon
as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver
just for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo
if you think that your rates may be too
high just check it out
see what's there see what's possible
subjects credit approval rates range
from 7.99 APR to 23.99 APR and include
0.50 auto pay discount
lowest rates require excellent credit
terms against the supply and offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com Theo for more
information
no I was uh I grew up in a house uh like
we had a half a house we only we had we
rented the bottom half of a house so
it's just all one level with rooms off
of the so we're all kind of crowded out
of three sisters and my mom and so when
I kind of came online it was hard to
hide it because I was just in my room
and whatever stuff was going on and they
all kind of became aware of it and that
was horrifying to me it was horrifying
that my mom and sisters were like aware
that like I think I heard them say oh
he's well that's what my mom likes was
just cheerfully saying well boys have to
touch their penises leave them alone and
she's like and I'm like stop mom because
my mom was just too nice you know like
she I had Playboy's hidden like hidden
as hard as I could hide them oh yeah in
under my bed in the I found a way to put
them in the slats or whatever but I'm I
was a boy so sometimes I would just jerk
off and then just leave the room and so
one day I came home and my mom had
cleaned my room and she stacked my
Playboys for me like stack them nicely
and I was it was just an acknowledgment
of my sexuality that I did not I was not
okay with was horrible and I appreciate
it now yeah
but uh man that's so interesting yeah
it's like our sexuality we don't we it
really is it's yours
and it's like kind of the only thing
that you especially like in American
culture you know it's very hidden it's
like
I don't know it's the only thing that I
had like I remember yeah I don't know
some whatever you're saying it kind of
makes me feel something it's like
that's my thing I think I felt a lot in
the world like I didn't have a like
everything else was up to someone else
right like the environment I was put
into the family I had to live with the
financial circumstance uh
uh the you know pedophiles or whatever
in our area all of that [ __ ] was
somebody else is doing you know but this
thing it's mine it's mine you know
that's a very profound thing you're
saying it's very true and so I think
because I've always had a tough time
with
like sexual connection you know like
like in my 20 like I couldn't even like
I had like so much sexual anxiety in my
20s it was like hard to even engage you
know so it was like
um but man yeah it's just interesting to
hear that kind of stuff yeah because
then you have you take this you discover
this thing and it is yours in in a
Wilderness in a world like you're saying
I think it's like that for any kid that
age
uh and then you have this weird task of
taking that into the world and offering
it to somebody else right and bringing
it to their mind
and combining it and that's very scary
and everybody has a hard time with that
I think I think that's fundamentally why
people have like societally societally
issues with sex and why there's always
sexual puritanicalism comes from one
place or another yeah is because
everyone has is not sure how to handle
that thing because it's so tender it's
like a very
like I did once and it's not something I
talk about a lot because it's very
private for me but I did um
uh the psychedelic drug like therapy
once you know like treatment with like
ketamine no it was uh MDMA and I did
mushrooms too but I put on uh you know
uh blindfolded so it's not like Molly
where you're at a party or something but
I went in deep and I saw this version of
my sexuality which was like I saw myself
as this baby like floating in space kind
of like with nothing around and then not
directly from the dick part but kind of
like the umbilical cord like somewhere
in between was this like purple like
cord
and I saw it as kind of like a Lifeline
but also an outgoing thing you know and
I saw it as like incredibly fragile and
like if you could have taken a bow from
a violin and and rung on it it would
have like made a crazy like you know
this sorrowful sound like it was just
like
and I saw it as like this deep want
but also something ancient about it like
to be I thought and the thought I had in
my head was you need to
um respect that
and you need to pity it like at the same
time wow it helped me a lot to look at
it that way and to see it as something
that just be careful with that it comes
from a very deep longing
but also a weird wisdom like there's so
much [ __ ] mixed in that yeah and it's so
like you passed out the first time that
you encountered it it's like it's just
so much and you're given it as a boy as
a [ __ ] boy you're going here it is
here's the craziest thing in the whole
world and it's yours now but it is it's
it's yours so yeah I mean to take that
and and and and and combine it with
somebody else and say I want to share
this with you
that is big stuff man and most people
wear they wear a lot of armor when they
do it yeah they wear a lot of armor they
would do a lot of they become somebody
else kind of people sexually a little
bit or you you play role or you do
something to to come at it in a way that
you know you're gonna survive it and be
okay and be you know what I mean but
satisfy it it's all it's it's
untanglable it's a [ __ ] mess for
everybody wow it is it is untanglable
yeah I had I had a girl to kind of break
up with me so I just started kind of
dating and we just kind of started then
she [ __ ] shut it down but I remember
being yeah thanks man
um
I remember being like the part that kind
of upset me the most was I told her that
I liked her huh and it was like it was
just so much risk in that for me like
admitting that I
yeah for some reason it was just so much
vulnerability around that like I'm gonna
say
I like you because I was afraid that the
truth would be that she didn't like me
and I think it goes back to some of
those like PRI like
this kind of pain that's not even I
don't know if it's mine but it's just
been in my [ __ ] cyst in my DNA or
somewhere that
that yeah you're gonna share you're
gonna say here I am yeah and somebody's
gonna say not today right you can sip
out the cream because you're the comic
because I don't I don't that I don't
have I don't
I love telling women I like them we love
it wow and I since I was a kid I was
like that when I started liking girls I
walk up to them and say you're just
beautiful and you're great and I want to
I want to go out with you or whatever
and then I in junior high school before
I'd ever kissed a girl I I learned a
thing which was that
all the hottest girls the top shelf
girls
they'll talk to you they like people you
know what I mean like they'd be aloof if
you're trying to pick them up but I
started making friends with them and I
got to know them really well like I talk
on the phone for hours with like the
hottest girls and I just like being near
them I just like knowing them you know
and I would tell them like I'm I'm I
would tell them I'm attracted to them
but I accepted that it wasn't you know
just I wasn't in the market right in the
marketplace but I never it never
bothered me the thing of telling I like
it if I meet a woman I like I kind of
want I have to I had to learn how to
slow down and not tell her too soon I
want to tell her right away yeah I want
to tell her before I meet her I want to
literally send out a mail now yeah yeah
you just want to say hey you I I want I
want you I like you I I you're great
this the thing about your face
particularly The Way You Walk yeah
because uh that admiration is just a
huge huge thing yeah but it never
bothered me to be rejected never
bothered me wow that's amazing because
most women uh even the snottiest women
would be nice about it you know if you
go up to the head cheerleader and like
you want to be my girlfriend she's like
oh she like give me an in give me an O
you don't get her but you know you get
to have a moment with her that's true
dude yeah there was nothing better than
like making a beautiful girl laugh that
was always like that you could do that
that's big
was like what this is a way that I can
get to women somehow like this is a way
this is the only way I have to come it's
like you know I think there's something
in that we're all just trying to use
some some way to get to one another you
know that's right
um it's natural it's how you you figure
out what's good about you and then you
put it out there you go here's my thing
yeah like the the angler fish that has a
glowing he's got a thing and it glows
oh it is deep sea anglerfish it's the
ugliest fish in the world I think it's
called a deep sea angler and he's got a
little stick on his head with a glowing
thing on it and it's a weakness
yeah the lures it's he lures chicks oh
yeah but that's actually the woman so
what happens is crazy what's fascinating
I just saw this the other night on a
show that fish
floats around with that thing on her
head and these the dude is really small
the dude is like this the size of like
her jaw and the dude sees that and also
gets the smell she puts a smell on the
in the water and he follows her and he
sees the light and this these folks live
in total darkness
they're in they can't see that they're
so below the surface there's no light
and they're still coming down there
they're still down there having a fight
yeah so so she she floats around just
like this with those [ __ ] up eyes in
the dark
and this dude sees when he sees that
glow like he's in darkness and then he
sees that glow and he's like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] and it's the odds are so low for
him because if he's not a [ __ ] great
swimmer he sees the glow but then he
watches it fade and he's [ __ ] and he
dies but the best of the anglerfishes is
how they select
he can get to it and he smells he get
that he uses the smell and the light and
then he latches himself he's got teeth
that latch under her belly oh and he
keeps biting and biting and she fights
him because she only wants the best yes
exactly like Marv Albert biting that ass
he didn't know what he really was you
know and then he finally latches on and
then his face becomes part of her belly
and if they fuse what and then he's
fused to her by the mouth
for the rest of his life and where's
this happening in Vegas
I mean for you could get anything in
Vegas no that's but then her bloodstream
is feeding him no and she she eats she
does life and it goes into him and he
just lays he just sits there and comes
he just constantly comes out of his
mouth into her belly and gets food back
and he's done he's like I don't need a
[ __ ] thing
this is yeah like the ultimate [ __ ]
that kind of guy who finds a woman and
latches he just latches on and they need
that lifelong connection because it's so
hard to find each other because it's a
Darkness yeah so she can't because she
can't keep looking for new guys so this
is it for them god dude that's honestly
one of the most romantic things
right but it's that glow so I don't
remember yeah so everybody's got their
you got whatever your glows you figure
out this is my thing and you put it out
in the world whatever it is no it's
laughing making girls laugh is
I remember being in uh at some party in
high school with kids always I always
felt like everybody was cool than me but
these were dudes that were like with
girls and everybody was cool and I was
just kind of I was starting to do drugs
yeah and I was starting to get cynical
and not like stuff and I was starting to
get kind of crabby about life you know
it just worked out well for you it has
and so these girls really cute girls
were with these guys and they were all
and they're all being dudes they're like
wearing shirts that show off their
shoulders and they're tanned and their
shoes fit yeah perfectly and they're
like cool dudes and they're starting to
get a little sensual like you know
getting into like their haircuts are
little 80s and stuff and they're all
talking one of them said something like
I don't remember the words but he said
something like this like impressive yeah
and I said like something like this like
[ __ ] you like yeah whatever buddy but I
said it well and the two girls
died laughing like they were they had
tears they were like oh my God because I
just destroyed the dude that they kind
of wanted yeah Bryce yes Bryce got
[ __ ] and Bryce looked at me like
what just happened no none of the dudes
understood what just happened who's this
wizard yeah and I was they were all
sitting in a circle and I was standing
above them and I remember looking down
at these girls and going I have a
[ __ ] power that none of these guys
have like I just made them come wow and
there's no way you guys have made these
girls come yet they're all everybody's
like 17 you know yeah but there is that
feeling when you're on stage you see
like a guy and a girl and a girl's just
crumpled and you're like I'm [ __ ]
your girlfriend right in front of you
yeah it is that's a win yeah it is
that's a win yeah it's like you have to
get seen somehow you have to get I'm
trying to think of
I would do it I I got people to laugh
because I didn't trust the world very
much and so I knew if people were
laughing that they couldn't not like me
and be laughing at the same time it was
like this moment of Solace like
yes it feels I I recognize that feeling
yeah it's like I could take a moment
um
I want to talk about your movie I want
to talk about your show from last night
I have to pee really fast
yeah LP too if you're gonna see it yeah
dude yeah
dude the show was awesome man oh last
night you came to my show yeah thanks
man man it uh
it is
yeah you are a I mean it is
I felt like
I felt like I left out of there with
like [ __ ] on my shoes kind of but it was
your [ __ ]
I didn't mean to [ __ ] on your shoes I
know you didn't but that's what I was a
comedian fellow comedians yeah I know
what you mean how long you been doing it
now I've been doing it maybe 18 years I
think oh it's not very long at all does
it feel is that true when you say that
yeah that's a really short amount of
time yeah I mean you really you got it
all ahead of you yeah I'm starting to
feel like that I realize that I need to
get out like I love telling stories so I
love telling stories and and uh like
Jerry Clower is like my favorite
comedian I'm familiar with him but he
was like he's one of the best selling
comedians ever like of like uh albums
and stuff but he was um like the
southern he was like this kind of
Southern Storyteller but I love that
kind of stuff but uh that's him right
there
yeah I know that face yeah so he um but
yeah I walked out and I was like Jesus
Christ who am I anymore this is what I
felt like walking out of your show like
are my beliefs intact I remember even
going like this when I walked out yeah
um what get what what gives you a kick
when you're up there like do you find
like is it still the humor that gives
you the kick is it an uncomfortability
is it like a control do you have any
sense of that kinda I think uh it's a
lot of things all at once that's
probably why I like it because there's a
shitload of things firing at the same
time you know it's a lot and but I'm in
control of it and in the ways that I'm
not are exciting it's like sailing in a
way it's like I know how to do all this
stuff but I'm still you know the wind's
still coming like this
and I'm healing a little and I'm like I
don't know guys but I've been I've also
got that veteran kind of I've seen this
I've seen this I know how this goes and
uh and the you know some shows are more
fun than others
the night before I shot this last night
for a special that's right and that's
coming out when like probably February
but I'm I'm I'm doing the Madison Square
Garden at the end of this month okay on
January 20th and I'm live streaming that
show on my website and people will be
able to buy it there but buy a ticket
yes they'll be able to buy the show and
watch it for like 10 days then I'm
taking it down I just want to share that
night wow because I used to play The
Garden all the time I haven't been there
in years and I don't want to return to
that to that I don't want to be an arena
comic I don't like the kind of pro
circuit thing anymore I just want to do
stand up because I love it but I got
back there and we sold it out I'm doing
it in the round I'm standing in the
center and so I want to just do it that
one night so I can really appreciate it
for what it is because when I used to do
it a lot it was like I just take the
subway into the garden
and I and there's a sadness that I
didn't see how great that was and now I
understand how great it was to have that
opportunity
so uh coming back there I'm calling that
special back to the garden and and so
folks can live stream and watch it
during the show wow and then I'll leave
it up for like 10 days just to stream
but then it'll come down and go away but
what I shot last night is it'll be the
same material but that's be my that's
the special for this year and that'll go
on your website that'll go on the
website for 10 bucks yeah
so dude yeah I would come yeah anybody I
like I I all I think I would maybe watch
it again and that's insane for somebody
to say these days watch anything again
yeah yeah yeah but because there's so
many things it's like it really is just
so many
levels of what's going on you know I
worked hard on this show and and but
anyway but so the night before we did
two nights because when you do a special
so I did uh Saturday night and that was
[ __ ] cream puffed that was just like
being massaged it just felt so good like
I just felt like it was easy and I'm
just like I'm on this one I'm like like
a kind of surfer who touches the water
wall while he's in there oh you know
what I mean like not the guy who's like
this but the guy who's like yeah he's
just doing this on the on the while he's
in the tube you know yeah he's kind of
like caressing just touching the nipple
of the ocean you know like that's what
Saturday night felt like and everything
was just I didn't have to think about
anything and it was the the perfect
thing for me is when I'm really feeling
the things I'm saying 100 I'm not in my
head about how's this show going what
comes next how do I say this is the pace
good I'm really thinking like here's
what I feel about Jesus like and I
really feel it and it was it just was
Sublime and great
um and last night was not as easy like
and coming off of that was hard that's
hard too because you can't yeah you
can't replicate the you can't cheat your
brain to know that you weren't on that
no you can't that high you can't and you
and you have to I mean it all comes with
experience so some early times in my
life a great show could ruin a a bad
show because the bad one I just go what
where are you what happened but once you
know like to me it's like the show is
going to be as good no matter what
I'm going to get the same outcome every
single show the difference is going to
be how much do I have to work for it you
know how hard so last night it was like
all right you [ __ ] and I had to really
more I felt like I had to really try
harder and probably when I edit it the
second show would probably be the better
show for watching because it's not fun
to watch a comedian be like hey man this
is great it's not the comfort of a
comedian it's not funny yeah it's
watching the guy test the water to see
if it's cold it's not as much the guy's
sitting in the hot tub that's right and
but the thing I guess one of the things
I love is going places because there's
some places where you know the laughs
are there's some places we know
everybody laughs at and it's fun to say
those things and be good at them and get
the laughs that you knew were coming but
I like taking people places where they
they don't even like to think about they
don't even like to let alone talk about
it or let alone hear about in a show no
but I know what's gonna come I know it's
gonna be okay so I don't I'm okay with
it's there's great power as a comedian
and being okay with uncomfortable
feelings with being okay with it you
just brought something up and they're
like [ __ ]
and that it gets tight in there and I
know that that tightness is useful and
that there's a place to take that and
then when they start to calm down a
little bit they're like I don't even
know where I am now this is a weird this
you see it in their face it's like like
I've never laughed at this before
and so I now I'm in a new place in my
mind that's I think a very powerful
thing about comedy yeah because it's an
opportunity to say stuff that's not
appropriate that's not all a comedy is
on some level of saying something you
shouldn't have said it's either you're
saying something because it's too
private like it's too you're over
sharing or which people love that you're
just gonna I'm gonna tell you this
[ __ ] up you do that a lot just like
I'm gonna tell you something really
personal yeah you need to know so you
shouldn't have said that because usually
in real in a real regular conversation
or in politics or whatever you don't say
things like that the other you shouldn't
have said is because it's so stupid just
a stupid thing everybody knows that's
not true what are you saying yeah the
other one is that's [ __ ] crazy that's
crazy that doesn't make any sense these
are all different kinds of humor but
they're all based in Satan something you
should have said and then the other one
is like man that's not cool that's not
cool to say that nobody likes that that
makes people mad and then there's just
like that's wrong that's that's morally
wrong to say that yeah and all of those
things if you can take people to those
places which are all fear places
fear of intimacy
fear of the insane which is a good
interesting kind of fear you know fear
of the of of of Truth or Fiction you
know and uh and fear of of uh uh
castigation by the by the masses you
know and fear of morality of Badness if
you can take people to those places and
make them laugh make them look happy to
be give them a make them feel like this
is okay then suddenly they're there
safely and that's expanding where you're
willing to go with your mind you know
because these are just this is a cage
you know and it keeps you from seeing
life there's so much to life
outside of what you're supposed to be
thinking about that's a that's a narrow
trip man you know so either way the trip
life is short so if you could do short
and narrower you can do short broad I
mean it's a little highfalutin but it's
how I feel about it no it's honestly how
I feel about doing stand-up
um it makes sense hearing you say that
and watching you and sometimes also it's
just Joe it's just I love the mechanics
of jokes yeah I love like I just got a
new [ __ ] joke oh there's no nothing
better dude it's literally like pulling
something out of your ass and getting
everybody to smell it and they like it
and they like it and now you're like I
have this yeah it I always think of it
as going healed you know like in the old
west like when I once I have a set like
after I put this special out it'll be
I'll be I'll be [ __ ] naked again I
have nothing yeah but when you go back
to the club and start getting then you
gotta set together and you put the gun
belt on like I can go anywhere now you
know it's just there is there is a power
rush to it I think also and it makes me
feel proud of myself like I used to
think
for some comedians it's about love it's
about feeling accepted and loved but for
me it's not that really because I feel
weird about that I feel weird when I
feel like when people stand up or they
they show a lot of adulation I don't
know what to do like it's not
comfortable
it doesn't make sense that doesn't feel
human oh that's interesting I can relate
to that yeah what I feel that's the big
thing up there is
like I'm doing I'm so I'm good at this
this is I'm nailing this I'm making them
happy everybody's happy the show's good
that's just I mean this is you're making
something good yeah it's very satisfying
you know it get better and better at it
I tried something I didn't think would
work you know like when I keep notes in
the beginning of a when I'm starting to
build a set there's always a section
that's like uh long shots you know stuff
that's never going to have long shots
Jesus I mean that's well the thing is
those long shots like things that when I
first did them the bottom was like oh
the crowd's like new and I'm like this
is one this one's gonna be hard but
every long shot I ever did ended up
being the big bits wow those end up
being the solid killer never fails the
memorable great bits yeah the bits that
I'd start with that were like this is
that's a slam dunk that's a slam they
start fading as the set gets more mature
because you don't love them as much no I
mean you like them yeah they're [ __ ]
but they're not [ __ ] wedding [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're all right but
yeah you know come over if I don't get
anybody else yeah yeah
wow dude yeah I uh
I can I I could totally understand that
I could see how yeah it's about it's
interesting it's not about the affection
it's about getting creating something
that makes you feel pride in yourself
yeah spreading yourself I mean it's a
little more self-love than it is Love
from them yeah I guess but that's okay
that's what we need you know I mean
we're all just trying to like find some
way to you know to feel okay
um yeah I've noticed I just started
telling more jokes like talking more
about Jews and stuff in my set a little
bit like because I've always just been a
freaks in La you can't even say the word
it feels like you just feel scared but I
didn't care just now when you said it
yeah I just didn't have any Jewish
people by us growing up so to me it's
just like but my Jewish friends are like
dude this [ __ ] [ __ ] is great it's
like but for a song I was just so scared
to even well here's why your Jewish
friends like it because they never hear
it and the thing is
the best way for people to get to know
each other is to hear the voice of
somebody who finds they're alienated
from a group and talking about them like
like I remember years ago Tracy Morgan
and I want to like get him and re in
trouble whatever oh he'll find a way
yeah he did a joke about if his son was
gay and
he said uh I'm gonna love him if my son
is gay I'm gonna love him like any
father loves any son
but if he comes in the room and is like
hey Daddy I'm gonna stab that a little
bit in the throat I know it just caused
70 problems but the bit was so brutal
and he got he was like an early version
of like you can't say that and he had to
go to like homeless gay centers and
listen to people that were you know
suffering and he had to go on a big
apology tour and and they and they shut
him down and I thought that was a shame
because there's such an opportunity in
that he's telling you what it's like to
be him where he's from and be and by the
way he's describing a conflict I'm gonna
love my son but I don't know how I'm
gonna handle him acting effeminate
because
my community my community doesn't honor
that and they think that is weakness and
yet I'm working and living in Hollywood
where I he's probably met gay people who
he looks up to now so that's why he's
got a conflict now totally so he the way
he dealt with the conflict is with
comedy by punching through it with a
funny brutal phrase and there's so much
to that there's so much to be learned
from that and for it it'll help people
uh on both sides do you know what I mean
yeah so it's for it's it's fun to watch
people that don't know a group talk
about that group yeah
that's how you see them huh yeah yeah
man that's how I see him I mean that's
where I came from it's exotic yeah
that's the joy of everything that's yes
that's what gives me any [ __ ]
excitement in the world like I love
think like I grew up in a you know black
white environment so I love thinking
about race and how it interacts and just
the surprises and I love that kind of
[ __ ] it's what even made me want to get
people to laugh sometimes was if you
could get black and white people to
laugh it was like you're the best
feeling of [ __ ] Elizabeth Taylor dude
no and you need any you need more of
both for it to work like if there's one
black guy in the room nobody white will
laugh at a race joke yeah but if there's
50 black people in the room they'll
they'll laugh and then everybody's
laughing yeah uh because yeah 49 on
other black people yourself yeah when I
worked at uh well that's I'm that's not
a worthwhile story but uh at least you
know that see that's the power of That's
The Power of the experience right there
yeah yeah let's cut bait with that one
that's yeah but I gotta tell you
something because like last night so
you know the feeling when you do like I
don't know how what level you work at
with stand up like what what's room you
would work around here not like do you
do theaters and stuff theaters yeah so
but the comedy store but I mean yeah
like I'll do a couple thousand seat
venue probably okay so when you do a big
show that's like a concert right it
leaves me feeling this very dry feeling
like there's adrenaline in my system
which is uncomfortable but also on now
I'm like suddenly you're backstage
you're alone yeah it's very strange yeah
they're all couples I mean I don't some
guys travel with an Entourage people
that keep them warm I don't do that yeah
so I have opening acts but everybody's
off in couples in groups having fun and
you're alone all of a sudden
so I'm always left with this [ __ ] and
last night I felt it a lot because I had
to put a lot of pressure on last night's
show because I needed to get clean up
anything I didn't do right night one and
it's for the special you know right
so I was cranky and tired and exhausted
and I went back to the hotel I felt like
[ __ ]
and I thought well I'm doing this guy's
podcast I don't I don't really know your
work yeah who you are I was I just
automatically respect that you're
successful because I know how hard
comedy is
but I thought I don't know the guy
should hear I should hear his I should
hear his voice you know I should hear it
so I just I'm kind of ready for bed I
don't want to do anything but I put my
phone on iTunes I found one of your
albums
uh it's like a picture of your face as a
kid
and what the [ __ ] is it called oh yeah
uh I want to say what it is because
um what is this where Zach can help this
is
wait tell them no sorry uh musket fire
musket fire
so I put on musket fires I'm kind of
getting ready for bed
and Jesus Christ I mean I was I was I
was looking for something to like maybe
I could pay him a compliment on
something like you know what I mean I
just want to be respectful I know who he
is and I was laughing so [ __ ] hard I
was La I was just out I don't know how
long it's been since the comedian has
done that to me I was just laughing my
ass off it's also a really good album
like it sounds good and it's I don't
know if this is what years this stuff is
from if he's probably from a few years
back yeah you're you're it you're like
hungry you're like a hungry comic but
you're so I mean I'm just looking at the
tracklist so I can remember the bits the
thing I mean where the the the
um the
where the title comes from where you
said about your father being 70. oh yeah
and that you're you were the only sperm
yeah and that you had to like shut the
wind you had to close up the nuts yeah
and then you pass to like a skeleton
sperm and you just sweep up and eat the
floors oh my God it was so [ __ ] funny
that and the and then this story about
uh Brad Pitt I mean you have a shitload
of weapons yeah you have like you know
like I think comedians as pitchers
sometimes like some guys have a fastball
yeah some guys are closer so they just
come with heat you know and other guys
have they can protect their fastball
with
off speed stuff you know what I mean I
mean you have long stories that you tell
that are are dizzying
I don't know how you come up with it's
like and every story has it's like a
Christmas tree with so many ornaments oh
thanks but then also when you're just
doing Straight Ahead observation about
life and sex and whatever just talking
generally which is two two things for
Comics is speaking about their
experience and their feelings and their
experiences one thing but then the other
one is like here's how I see the world
and you do both with like a [ __ ] it's
strong as [ __ ] I mean thanks man I
listened to then I listened to the other
album the the the hamsters in the back
oh yeah
you called it uh uh Louisiana Ivory or
something like that right oh yeah the
ivory of Arkansas dude Arkansas yeah
because they busted a guy with uh
hamster bones in our town yeah and you
said you figured out it must have been
like 2 000 hamsters or something we had
to have a lot and this story where
you're in um bathing suits with your
friend you're we're in wet bathing suits
surrounding a bunch of monkeys in a
Wendy's parking lot which is a poem of a
sentence is there any truth to that
story that really happened yeah that
happened in uh because our town was
where thank you for the compliment
that's nice of you sure
um it'll probably be one of the best
comments ever get well it was shocking I
was like how do I not how have I never
heard this guy yeah what [ __ ] great
thank you well it's crazy how we just
don't get you know some people you don't
know about people yeah
you know yeah well comedians are single
we're not even like tennis players that
are one-on-one we're just one right
we're like kings on the chessboard you
know you know I can't you can't sit on
the side by side squares yeah it's yeah
that's really interesting you kind of
just marvel from afar yeah which I think
in a weird way is how I've always
connected with people anyway is just
this space yeah there needs to be this
space you know to have a connection so
getting even closer even more vulnerable
even with comedy and stuff is a thing
that's like how that's one thing I'm
watching you I'm like Jesus Christ how
what part of this dude is even talk like
how is this guy
speaking from the bottom of a [ __ ]
Wishing Well of himself like
where or what like you're and it's like
I don't even know what part of me is
listening to you it's like it's like a
[ __ ] violent baby yeah that likes to
[ __ ] and and he
is front row and he has no diaper on
yeah but he's [ __ ] right there and
I'm like where has he been I didn't know
he was in me and then I see couples
watching you yeah and I'm like does
Louis I almost feel like he Marvels at
their ride home in the car yeah I do
think about that yeah
how does what do the groups say to each
other
what do two guys say to each other you
know because there's that that's hard
for people to talk about something like
that after I think
they don't want to they don't want to be
the first to say they liked it or didn't
like it yeah some people don't like me
on in my audience I can see it I see
faces of people going like
This Isn't that cool man and they can't
I appreciate that they can't like I used
to think like why the [ __ ] are you here
then well because you don't if you need
to look at a bunch of faces just loving
you
but it's interesting to look at people
that are just like you know and it's
interesting to me that they came
it's like going to a fire but being like
kind of like yeah
people do people like to they want to
see they want to see that's I think
that's different about comedy than music
Wow music you're a fan otherwise you
don't waste your time but when a
comedian gets bigger I think there are
people who are like well I want to find
out I I don't like him or I haven't I
don't like what I've heard yeah but and
there's also people I used to have it
more but you see that there's people who
just came because you're you're you're a
name right and they really didn't pay
attention and some of those people are
horrified you know I mean at the height
of my career I had people I could see
people leave because they're like I
didn't know he was going to talk about
any of this [ __ ] you know and it was
weird because the build up to it is just
only people who loved what I did it's a
when you get
at the first stage of getting notoriety
is only devoted fans who love what you
do telling their friends and that grows
exponentially but it's still people they
only tell a friend they know will like
it so you have just a perfect crowd for
a while oh yeah but then if you get more
popular people start coming because they
heard about you you start being more
accidentally noticed yeah people want to
yell sometimes people just want to come
and yell something yeah they just want
to be at a thing so you're starting to
get more kind of like casual fans and
they don't and they're not fun they're
not into it yeah and it starts getting
you feel the way it starts getting heavy
you start getting the whole thing gets a
little waterlogged there's a I think it
happens to every comedian I think and
there's a couple of couple a few years
of my career where I felt like I was
starting to get a little shitty because
I just wasn't I was losing my bearings
you know
that's fascinating man it really is it's
interesting to hear because yeah I've
had experiences where it's like you get
so many fans and podcasts and help
create that um yeah and this other
alternative world you know like because
you were you had a I mean
one thing that you'll be able to say for
yourself I think even as a human by the
time you get to the end of your life is
you've gotten to have almost every
experience
do you think so I think so you've got to
have a lot of them did you it seem what
do you mean I mean I don't know about
all your experiences but you've gotten
to have success you've had success like
in the mainstream version yes and then
this other version and I don't and I'm
I'm paraphrasing myself because I don't
know exactly what I'm saying but
um this other version of success like
kind of in this alternative ver in this
you know do it straight to your fans
yeah straight to Consumer
um the movie The Fourth of July like
yeah dude unbelievable I was sitting
there sending Joe list messages like
dude you are so [ __ ] good he's good
right oh and it just captures who he is
yeah much it's like how do we get this
special piece of Joe that's like
just so like perfect you know that was
the exercise yeah I mean it was
it was awesome it made me in Spa it just
I can't believe you guys nailed the
ability to capture everyone but you've
got to have and we'll talk about uh
Fourth of July in a second
um
but you have everything now through your
website and you can but what has that
been like because you had this
mainstream success that is very glitzy
and glammy and it's like a lot of us
chose podcasting because there wasn't
that opportunity there right so this
alternative Universe kind of was created
um what is what has one been like in the
other been like well I mean I had first
so many years of just struggling you
know like uh I started when I was a just
18. I think the first time I ever did it
I was 17 but I started really trying at
18 in 1985. it's a long [ __ ] time it
goes 38 years now wow but from 19 from
1985 and when I was 18 Till I was you
know he was a Boston comedian for years
just trying and failing and and uh and
then I moved to New York and I started
to get some sense of power but but and I
tried writing for TV is a way to make a
living because I just wasn't making it
as a comic but as a stand-up I worked
until it wasn't really until I was like
40 that I started to really like hit so
I had all those years so that's like a
whole other you know right right people
kind of forget about that yeah I wasn't
trying to discredit you no no I hadn't
put your time feel that at all okay but
after that then I had yeah I had this
big and the biggest part of it was the
stand-up I mean that's what fueled it
all was that I was selling out theaters
all of a sudden and they couldn't get be
big enough like I would double the size
and sell it out I would put a show on
sale and it would sell out in a minute
and
um
and there wasn't a room in the world
like there wasn't an indoor space in the
world I couldn't book
like we would me and my agent would talk
about where do you want to play like
let's go to London Royal Albert Hall if
you feel like at Wembley Arena yes any
place Stonehenge yeah [ __ ] Madison
Square Garden weird amphitheaters and Mr
McGregor's Garden anywhere anywhere it
was crazy like I remember I was talking
to one point about playing Central Park
you know like Simon Garfunkel did like
it was crazy
and then the TV thing you know I mean I
had that show and it hit
but it wasn't like friends or something
it wasn't like you know what I mean it
wasn't a network show with a huge reach
there's still a [ __ ] a ton of people
that never saw it it had pretty low
ratings in my show it got a lot of press
and rewards and stuff and not even as
many awards as other shows it wasn't
like the office or something right but I
loved the work I loved I was getting to
do the show exactly the way I wanted so
I had a huge fulfillment that way and
yeah it was weird I was getting Awards
and I was at awards shows and stuff like
that and I would meet somebody like Brad
Pitt and he'd be like oh dude and that
kind of strange feelings and
um I'm sure and your ego has to build
even if you don't know it the ego's so
that's right that's the thing that's you
that you got to be careful of you don't
know what your ego is doing you're just
success is very dangerous because
there's no warning signs on it there's
nothing cautionary about it in the
experience you just believe in it you're
just like this is all happening because
I'm good at this and because it's my
time and and here we go and anything
good that happens you go sure I'll do
that too yeah and you just keep letting
it load on and you don't
think about like you're seeing the uh
American Gangster it's Denzel Washington
yes
there is the that you're watching him
quietly build this huge Empire and then
it's when he goes out in the white uh uh
fur coat to the fight he goes to a box
you mentioned white for coat and then
the head cop the Russell Crow goes who's
that guy and he's not aware that
somebody has just gone wait a minute
who's the guy in the white fur so when
you're like big getting bigger and
bigger somebody out there is going like
what's going on with that guy that guy's
flying awfully high and you you just
don't you're not aware of that you just
go this just keeps being good I'll do
next year I'll do 10 shows of the garden
I mean where does that go where do you
think that's going like now I look at it
like where do you thinking that's headed
like it just can't things that expand
explode right yeah it's unsustainable
for most artists in the world I mean
every comedian has that's even gotten
that big there's been some comeback to
Earth moment everybody every buddy who
gets that big right has whatever their
vulnerability is whatever their thing is
they're Achilles heel it's going to get
hit yeah because the world tests you and
it's also just more interesting to watch
somebody go down it's just part of life
life is a zero-sum game you know oh yeah
so but so yeah but having done stuff
like hosting Saturday Night Live Like a
bunch of times like that was never that
wasn't in my
in my sights like I didn't think these
things would happen to me I had
completely you're really not I
completely had given up on those things
happening to me I just admitted to being
a writer you think yeah I thought I'd
I'll never stop doing stand-up I thought
because I love it it's it's the thing I
love
but I can write I'm a good writer I
tried making films early and they
crashed and burned so I'm like I'm not
going to be a film director either those
are the Big Dreams like direct movies be
a comedian
I'm gonna do comedy but no one's ever
gonna love it and I'll go down for
whatever I was maybe pulling in a you
know a few hundred people a night down
it'll just diminish and someday I'll
have to give it up and I'll write and
that'll be okay I'll make other people
famous make Chris Rock famous make Conan
you know help other guys get there and
there's joy in that I Chris I love Chris
this is my favorite growing up yeah he
he astonished me when he came back to
stand up after SNL and get inspired me a
lot he was he's one of the best friends
I've ever had and uh he was great but
when he was just my boss I just loved
him he was the greatest greatest guy he
used to say like you know I'm not it's
not about me world because he he hired
writers that were all really good and he
said we're all the Yankees I'm I'm in
the I'm in the cleanup spot but I'm just
the guy who has this one role but you're
all you know you made us feel like we're
all part of it right so I liked that
work but I had no I had really decided
and I started I had a kid and I was like
this is not
it's not gonna never gonna happen for me
and then if something changed because
when I went on stage I just didn't I
didn't care anymore about my a career so
and I was really cranky and I was
starting to really I went through a new
cranky phase and I was a tired father
and and I started talking about that and
then things then things changed you know
did it surprise you yeah it really it
really did talk to me and then when I
got the the show on FX the the the they
paid me the minimum I got paid like you
know scale yeah and the show had the
smallest budget of any show on
television but the point was and it was
on FX which was nowhere at the time I
mean they had a few cool shows yeah but
people didn't know about it no so I
thought I'm gonna do a show and I'm
gonna love it
and it's never going to take off it's
just going to be a little show my friend
Laura kitlinger had done this show yeah
called The Adventures of Jackie
something and Laura's one of the
funniest people I knew and she did a
nice season on like AMC and I thought
that's what I'm gonna do one season of
this weird little show and then I'll go
back to them I'll get another writing
job that's what I figured I had no
[ __ ] and then we're like you know
then we're getting on the big lists and
then we got Emmy I was totally shocked
that that happened
um but then after a few years I'm like
yeah this is you know it's like if you
play Blackjack you start winning you get
stupid right away you're like I'm good
it's because I'm good at Blackjack yeah
yeah because I know what I'm doing
and then they just then you're busting
every hand you're like no I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so yeah I was in a place where I
thought like I this is happening because
I know what I'm doing now because I'm
earning it uh but a lot of it is just so
weird you caught a wave you caught a
wave it was good timing yeah it's
interesting how some comedians don't
even get the time it's like they're
where they're what their funny is in
their lifespan it just doesn't match
with the wave of like where Society is
sometimes that's right there's some
people that are incredible but they
weren't that at the right time that's
one of the biggest challenges in comedy
is just staying good when nobody's
paying attention and continuing to
progress because it's like this
Searchlight that maybe finds you
sometimes and if every time it finds you
you're you're getting better and better
then the then someone in the somebody in
the world will start to go this guy is a
good bet they'll start putting money on
you yeah but uh but anyway then when I
when I started to pull in the when it
became like total like just nothing
failed area yeah on the road because
stand-up was always the most important
thing foreign
I thought an interesting way to leverage
this would be
to make a connection with the fans
through this website because I could
have started taking huge checks from Big
promoted companies you know just those
there are tours where they just give you
the money first right right it's like
here's seven million bucks or whatever
yeah and then we're gonna charge your
fans 600 a ticket right you know we're
gonna sell and then we're gonna sell
those tickets to our own reseller you
know to [ __ ] we're gonna make money
that way and we're gonna give you they
can do stuff like we'll give you a jet
Verizon's paying for the jet and now you
have a Verizon sign above your you know
they have you have sponsorships on the
tour and then they they load on other
comedians that they owe money to that
they're trying to burn off the money and
you're doing rooms that are just awful
that they own you know it's just but
it's seven million dollars here you go
that's what you get for your 30-year
climb that's what that's you know right
um but to me it was more interesting to
go because I I was interested in like
Ticketmaster has all the emails they
know those are the Glenn Gary leads they
have but if I make a website and sell
directly to people and I think about how
I don't like buying stuff when they ask
me for my email I don't like it yeah I
hate it I don't like belonging to stuff
I don't like joining right I don't want
to do that to my fans either no so we
just make it that you just pay the five
bucks and it's in five dollars was this
like crisp little number
and then you have it and I don't care if
you [ __ ] share it don't be a dick and
make money on it but I don't give a [ __ ]
that much it's never gonna it's not
gonna ruin my life if other people share
my products right and at the time this
idea of protecting your product was
getting bigger
because digital was new you know and uh
and then I got your email and and if if
you want to give me your email you have
to give it to me like we made it hard to
give to get on the list
so I got this little list that started
growing and it just that saved my life
because that's I still have that list is
getting bigger and bigger but it's
that's who I go to now
um has that been do you find more do you
miss the notoriety of not even a little
bit interesting not even this and that's
true that's 100 true I don't miss it I
don't the thing I just do I mean I've
been torn for three years right right
yeah it is all over the world and big
places a lot of my friends have been
working with you on and off over the
years and I I know that for sure but
yeah I guess I was wondering do you miss
that Hollywood style kind of notary
because that's the two that's the things
that that podcasters always miss a
little bit they're not like in this it's
so funny to me too because like I've
heard like Shane is a buddy of mine and
he's got a you he puts sketches on
YouTube and hundreds of thousands of
people watch them and people worship
Shane and he sells out big places and
he's having a great time and he's like
I'll never get on television yeah like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
like what is your problem yeah it's like
a guy who invented the the Telegraph and
he's like they'll never let me on the
Pony Express like you just killed the
Pony Express
what the [ __ ] worried about
this has so much more power that [ __ ] is
dead and it's still you know you think
about I grew up thinking about The
Tonight Show oh that's what everybody
thinks about if you could do
Jimmy Kimmel every night for six weeks
and kill and you ain't gonna sell one
ticket off that nobody's watching
Comedians and they don't even know where
to find you no this this [ __ ] it spreads
it's on every it's all over the it's
crazy you have the same bandwidth
as NBC ABC or any of them yeah and and
but the difference is you got something
people are never they you fans you have
from doing this they're Never Gonna Let
You Go
you're gonna stay yeah so it's a
blessing it is and when you can go to
direct it's just I do stand up now and
people come and we have a great time and
they pay me
and what the [ __ ] else could I possibly
want these These are people I care about
they they went out of their homes I know
[ __ ] got a babysitter and parked
somewhere and then sat politely in a
[ __ ] seat with strangers and listen
to me and gave me a [ __ ] ton of money I
mean when I went back to clubs first I'm
like I'm in clubs again like that's all
that's all I got I thought that might
hurt my that's I didn't know if I would
feel like this
but when I first was like the St Louis
funny moment I remember
you know the soda thing is right next to
you going likes feeding soda to the bar
oh yeah you're in a back room with just
soda machine that was one of the last
ones you could smoke in too yeah you
could it's still oh you can't good they
had the early smoking show
and uh I was like here I am but I went
on stage in that place you know the
crowd is just all around you and it's
hot you feel a heat like you could see
kind of like a like steam coming off of
them oh yeah and it's a dump yeah you
feel like if you just pushed one of the
walls hard enough the whole club would
fall down yeah and uh and I had a
[ __ ] ball I had such a good time and
it was hard work I did like two Friday
two Saturday like the old days
and then I got paid and I'm I'm for
whatever I am I I can still get 80 90 of
the door yeah and 89 of the door of a
comedy club after you know Thursday
through Saturday that's crazy money now
play in the garden and then another
Arena the next night for 20 nights in a
row is astronomically more but I don't
feel that money I don't need you know
what I mean that doesn't feel like more
right it's just like yeah that's a [ __ ]
ton of money it's all gone now because
I'm stupid and I because I made movies
with it I'd make my own stuff with my
own money now
but that [ __ ] funny bone check I was
like who needs more than that man that's
and and um with comedians I love I'm
choosing my openers we're having fun
together
um and yeah I called enough money
together to make that movie with Joe and
we don't get you know I don't get
written about I'm not you know when I I
made two specials over the last years
and yeah does that hurt no it doesn't it
really doesn't because
a [ __ ] ton of people buy them on the
site and folks that want I'm back to
that place where if you're watching me
it's because you really want to hear
this these jokes it's not because you
want to like you know
see what this means inside the culture
or you don't want to you're not trying
to clam on to act cool because you like
me it's just you're into the comedy yeah
if you're if you're watching me you're
into the comedy there's no other reason
to do it
and I like that and I have
my friends in the industry and in my
community my Pro I have my real friends
I lost a lot but now I have real friends
and I love them and and I love their
success doing that with Joe is a big
thing for me because that was his story
it was his voice so given a movie to a a
young guy you know who I just thought
was worthy and somebody should listen to
this guy and I don't think anybody else
is gonna make a movie for him
so
that felt great and it's a small it's a
small movie it's got a small scale you
know it's not like some like whoa it's
just a [ __ ] real story so I got to do
that and it's it's inching towards
making its money back it's just it's
just you know it costs a lot because of
the pandemic was oh that's aggressive to
shoot during the pandemic but uh but no
it's really good it's a and and I I I I
I don't know you can you can have a life
like that you don't have to take every
every opportunity I don't think that
that Hollywood notoriety that membership
of that club
it's not really good for you I don't
think it it's cool
it's a fun trip if you can make the trip
if you can get that big yeah go on the
trip
if you can go on some red carpets yeah
have fun it's a it's worth experiencing
if you can host Saturday Night Live go
[ __ ] do it make the most of it and do
your best and try to be yourself try to
it's really everybody that has made it
and had a real like like you're saying
at the end of life going I I did all
this it's could you stay yourself during
it because if you're not yourself if you
change in order to stay in those places
because that's the first thing they'll
ask you to do oh yeah that's what I was
trying when I got to Los Angeles then if
you do that then you're not the one
experiencing it anymore you're lost
you it's not you you became somebody
else to do that and then you start
getting this weird feeling about that
yeah that's so interesting I was I've
been a part of things where it's like I
don't feel like this is me and it's
because I wasn't choosing it it wasn't
me choosing it so then of course it's
not going to be me that shows up to it
every day no that's a fascinating note
for anybody next to this could be a
relationship a job anything you're in if
you're wondering why something doesn't
feel right all the time or doesn't fit
or you're not showing up the same way
that feels comfortable to you it's
because of that very reason right there
yeah because you kind of Desire can come
from a lot of things it's not always
internal sometimes it's like I've been
told I want this or this feels like this
might get me out of where I am this
seems like what I should be doing yes or
it might be a step that that feels right
to me I've seen other people do that
or or sometimes just like maybe this
will get me out of my misery maybe this
will change everything that kind of
thing but the thing you got to ask
yourself is is am I being Theo when I
take this step forward like what would
he do because and if it looks so good
but you're like that ain't me man the
you say to yourself yeah but it's okay
because I'll take that step and then
there'll be another me step past that
but there's no more you like if you take
one step that's not you right you have
nowhere to put the next foot the next
it's not you anymore you like your yard
you're not nowhere but if you take a
step that's like this seems like a bad
idea this is hard nobody likes this
but it's me man what am I gonna do then
when you take that step the great thing
is no matter what comes at you all you
got to do is lift your foot and plan it
again you're still you you can you get
you through hard times
and it'll keep you available for Good
Times
as yourself you know there's nothing
there's nothing else there's nothing
else all that stuff it's
it's got a gross side to it but if
you're yourself again if you can be
yourself in it you can observe it
you can find love there there's love
everywhere so you can find friends and
you can find interesting things you know
if you're in an award show there's
people working the cameras and stuff and
like a lot of them were people I knew
from like Conan like group members so
I'd beat it in award show going like I
shouldn't be here and then I'd see you
know a guy like hey and I go hey there's
love there you know yeah or a weird
actor I worked with for some on some a
long time ago and he said you know there
is people there's you can find a loving
and a self path
through anything but if you depend on if
you're like I won't feel good if
everybody if I'm not a Hollywood
a-lister
you might as well [ __ ] pack it in
that's it's not a good way to live
yeah man it's just it's so interesting
to hear some of that because I've had
spots even in this past couple years my
life where I chose to do certain things
and I'm like I know this doesn't feel
right but I feel like I need to do it
for money or I feel like I need to do it
for and once I got out of some of that
everything has fallen so much more into
place I've gotten a semblance of human
like I just feel like myself more again
it's been pretty fascinating good
um when it comes to like love in your
life has that been a tough thing I find
like as a comedian like I get so
analytical about stuff and obviously we
were talking a little bit about how like
getting him into emotional spaces can be
like a real uh you know that can be like
a real
it's a real it can be a tough space
sometimes for comedians
um has it been sometimes I noticed even
with like being in love or something
like that I'll like I'll be analyzing it
so much it's hard for me to actually be
in the feelings yeah because I'm like
it's like to be in the feelings you
almost have to let go of some control
kind of yeah you know and so have you
had experiences like that in your life
has it been kind of tough or what's that
kind of been like because I know you've
had you've been married and you've been
married I've got two kids that's a
different kind of love it's that's a
forever it's a love you just have it's
like you can't choose that was that hard
for that because sometimes I fear that
like
because love seems so negotiable
sometimes I think because it was like
that when I was it felt like that when I
was a kid yeah that I worry that it's
gonna be like that if I'm a parent how
is it negotiable when you're a kid you
mean conditional you mean like it can go
away if you don't do the right thing or
something yeah yeah I think like if you
don't uh
uh yeah if you're not like
I don't know if you're not something
then
you don't deserve something you know or
something like that you know
yeah I I have a dog do you have a dog
uh-oh I've got a dog and she's like my
wife now like it's me and her you know
and uh we I mean my kids are in my life
and we have a great joy but my dog's
with me every single day when I'm home
oh wow and uh
I was with my dog once and I'd smoked I
don't smoke weed very much
but I went to Washington Square Park and
just bought some weed and it was I think
it was a little a little much oh yeah
some weed makes people gay even
no but I was uh I was like
uh getting existential and weird you
know yeah but my dog came over and sat
with me so I just kind of hung on to her
and I said to her you know you don't
have to do anything you don't ever have
to do anything I said you don't have to
worry
you don't have to try you don't have to
be sorry you don't have to promise
uh you don't have to regret all you got
to do is sit there and just take the
love that's coming at you that's all you
got to do is just be
and just take the love that's just
coming and then I thought I could say
that to myself too I could say that's
anybody you know I mean if you're
willing to just be yourself and just sit
there yeah it's it's hard that sometimes
you're just alone sometimes you're just
lonely sometimes you don't find somebody
you don't find love but once you have
kids it's it's a tricky thing with kids
too because you want to love them and
and then you also got to let them go you
also got to let them depart your life
you got to let them my kids are 18 and
21 now 17 and 21 about 18 a few months
but they they start to you know and yet
and then it turns into a different
everything that takes away from you
gives you get another it's a zero-sum
game yeah so your kids aren't little you
know holding your hand anymore
but you can watch a movie and make fun
of a movie together you know what I mean
right talk about life and be friends and
that's incredible with somebody who you
used to wipe her little face you know
and now you're laughing at a [ __ ]
shitty movie together talking about how
shitty this movie [ __ ] sucks cursing
together you know yeah that's really
something oh yeah I want to curse my
[ __ ] kid yeah you need to have kids I
think I think you should have kids yeah
and I don't know I mean the the that
love with uh with a woman with a partner
that's a lot harder because you're both
armed with self-protection and stuff
yeah totally and so I think the thing
you got to be willing to just try it and
fail you have to it has to be okay for
you that if it doesn't work out because
it mostly usually doesn't I think it
should be okay with people that you
combine with somebody and you try and a
bunch of stuff doesn't work and you [ __ ]
some and you have fun and you do
something exciting like having kids
together and then when it's just when it
starts to rot you get the [ __ ] out
it's okay just get out you're done your
dad did it you just get you know my
daddy like you know my parents broke up
vamanos yeah thank God my parents broke
up yeah yeah that's a great Point huh
sometimes I romanticize things to the
point where if the re if I were able to
look at the reality of it yeah I would
see that it's a [ __ ] nightmare you
know but I can't get there sometimes in
my head because I get stuck so much in
the romanization well because your
feelings are you yeah your feelings run
a lot of your life and you can't reason
with them I know it's crazy isn't it you
made them I don't know
I don't know who the [ __ ] is inside I
don't know I don't it's his big [ __ ]
mystery
but uh
yeah you can't you're in a thing with
somebody especially young I don't know
it gets easier when you get older like
now when I meet somebody if I'm starting
to get romantic with somebody with this
conflict I just go yeah I can't we're
not we don't need to do that do we like
you you get to it quicker right then
when you're younger you get you start
having us like you're too you're like
playing uh Battleship where you have a
you can't yeah you're driving past each
other's house you put a Nair in each
other's shampoo I put mayor in a girl's
shampoo yeah it is oh my God [ __ ]
pretty awesome
yeah dude those are the days cause we
had to do it
and she she still tries to hook up with
me you know by the way there's a bit of
yours in that first album that has a
potential you touched on something and a
great idea for a bit and you didn't
finish it yeah I've heard a few Comics
do that you know uh-huh you're talking
about farts
and you have first of all you have a
take on it I've never heard which you
say I hate farting I've just never heard
anybody say that yeah I hate farting but
at the end of the bit you say toward it
to yourself you go we gotta we gotta get
we gotta beat him we gotta beat farts we
gotta beat him and you just sort of say
it a few times we got to beat him the
idea of that there's a cure for farts
it's a [ __ ] hilarious that we need to
find a cure nobody's even thinking about
curing farts
that's a great I mean that to me that's
like I want you to go there right no I
appreciate it man uh yeah you had some
great you had some cool material about
that last night man
you don't give me a chance that it's
like that's why I'm like do I have to go
back and watch it again because I don't
even have a CH before I'm processing
[ __ ] I'm like so far into the [ __ ]
fun house there's like a disabled man
eating my ass dude and I'm trying to
[ __ ] order a Ruben it's like I
literally don't even know what's going
on dude maybe I'm going too fast maybe I
should go um I do want to talk about
Fourth of July man I'm in recovery I got
like eight months so okay it was thank
you and it so it was nice for me to just
see those guys you know and uh and just
like a part of it that people don't like
the like Joe's sponsor calling him
no worries take care take a moment
water down the wrong pipe
isn't that crazy man yeah when water
tries to like [ __ ] our lungs no you can
die oh yeah if you get a lot well I mean
that's what it feels like yeah it's
really every all the comfort you have
that you're alive
you could just squeeze this little
put a little bit of water like it's
probably this much water
and it's like I'm done I'm dying
dude if I have tuna fish because a lot
of times if you know when you're coming
up you have to cook in your hotel room
in the you know yeah yeah so I'd mix
like tuna and stuff in a uh a hot plate
or something or no just in a styrofoam
cup okay and then
um
but if I had Gatorade electrolytes and
tuna my throat would shut down I didn't
know oh really some crazy reaction
so yeah one time I I was [ __ ] losing
I I've called 911 I'm losing it it was
the first time that it happened I got
really scared and I went up to this uh
not a maitre d what's a lady that helps
clean the room clean the hotel
definitely not a major day yeah you mean
the maid lady yeah yeah or may yeah yeah
um when I've turned on like [ __ ] you
know like trying to [ __ ] do like this
you know any Gatorade you know
like fish and Gator oh bro and I
remember putting literally putting my
fingers in my throat and [ __ ] holding
it open enough so I could breathe like
wow but it's just when that pipe it's
like the littlest thing man no man
you're gone that's why waterboarding
works all it just you could go like this
and I'm like I'll tell you everything oh
forget it
um the movie was so great how can I ask
you just as a how much does it cost to
make a movie like this I know you said
it was more during the pandemic it's way
too much okay it was like something like
two million bucks okay that movie
shouldn't cost that much but there's two
reasons one was the pandemic because
that just it was like 30 more everything
cost 30 more right and then the other
thing was that I was coming back to I
hadn't filmed anything in a long time
and because the pandemic had happened
and I just wanted to really enjoy it I
wanted to really make a movie and not
worry about it low low budget movie just
means you're dragging your balls on the
gravel and it's just every single single
thing you do is hard and everybody
around you is stressed out because
nobody's getting paid enough and you're
working bad hours and stuff I just
didn't want to do it I just wanted to
like so we we did a comfortable version
of it it still was very low budget
that's still a very low for Fourth of
July movie you sorry yeah yeah but uh
but and also we shot in this house that
that was the heart the biggest expense
probably was the house because we had to
find I couldn't make the movie unless
that house was the exact right kind of
law a roomy Log Cabin had to be on a
lake and it had to be in a place that
felt like Maine it was actually in
Upstate New York and Lake George and
that was a and a place that's willing to
be rented it's a house so we the place
there's like a list usually of location
people that put themselves out there as
were available none of them worked so I
had to have a guy
I the location guy is a guy named Jeff
Karen
from Louis from my series and I went to
him and asked him to do it and he said I
don't do that anymore I'm retired like
he has a whole other life and I just
begged him and he came out at retirement
just just for me so he because he had to
just go real estate listings and go hit
the [ __ ] bricks all over like
Northern America you know and go to
people's doors and knock on him and say
are you willing to be a location that
kind of cold calling it was very hard to
find the right place and then once we
found the place that was willing they
could have double the price we still
would have paid it because so it cost a
lot and and then we put Lake George is
in this little town where it's really
expensive so every there's no Hotel so
we had to find housing we had to find
like basically vacation homes for the
whole cast and crew and that was the
hugest anyway it's a long explanation
but it's a lot it shows how much goes
into all that yeah a movie like that
should you should be able to make it for
under a million bucks it's it's so it's
just people talking it's pretty simple I
mean we shot in New York City to which
is expensive so for the first like 30
minutes of the movie
um but there's a lot of ways there's so
many cameras now that are have as good a
sensor as any other camera and the great
lenses of the world you can rent and
everything else is rentable and there's
people that have film equipment who are
dying to use it now because they
overbought and
and uh you can usually pull I mean the
unions are are strict and you have to
use Union Crews most of the time
so if you're really trying to make a
movie with like a you know carpentry
department and electrical and and grips
and everything yeah it's hard to keep
the cost down a bit but if you just do
what you're friends with a camera you
can do it for whatever cost to rent the
clothes and you know yeah it's
interesting once you go over that Union
line once you get into like that's when
once somebody calls their agent you're
[ __ ] that's right yeah that's just the
way it is yeah it's expensive
um
it was it yeah man I just thought it was
incredible that moment
I don't want to give it away really but
there's a nice moment where the dad
comes into the room with Joe yeah yeah
with the phone yeah it's funny because
it's so subtle well he had a whole
speech that he gave oh he didn't took it
out
yeah that was the kind of like the point
of the whole movie was that he gives his
speech that's what I was kind of way I
was waiting for that a little but then I
just accepted that it was just yeah it
was weird because we did so
when we wrote it it was all about this
dad even though he says nothing through
almost the whole movie he's totally
silent and and Joe and his mom are just
at loggerheads
and uh she runs the family and he's
trying to become an individual but be
loved by her and it's impossible she's
withholding like your mom sounds like
she was didn't know how to love you know
so he's dealing with that but you just
see once in a while we go to these shots
that are just quiet private shots of the
dad
like not knowing how to deal and Joe has
a big anxiety disorder that we kind of
portray through weird filming and at one
point we show that the dad also has yes
oh I didn't catch that I did but I
didn't yeah the key's kind of like an
undiagnosed older guy with he's got an
anxiety disorder but nobody told him you
know nobody told that generation yeah
there was like a thing wrong with him so
he's dealing with that and then and then
at the end when Joe feels like he's kind
of figured stuff out he comes in and
says this thing and it was this speech
where he says
he starts trying he's struggling to talk
because he doesn't he's because he's an
anxious guy he's socially anxious
and he starts telling him about he was
he said when I played football
um I was a lineman in high school and we
were playing Brockton High and he tells
the story about seeing the quarterback
and that he could sack him and win the
game
but uh he hesitated and the guy laughed
at the passover's head and but he did in
the past missed anyway
and then he's about to kind of make his
point in the phone rings
and he gives up
so he gets he gets through the story but
it doesn't make his point but we we
played it that way and it just felt it I
believed in it so much when we shot it
when he was the guy who was acting it
Bob Walsh we were all crying everybody's
crying Joe was crying everybody was and
I was like this is the thing but then
you watch the whole movie and you go I
don't want to [ __ ] listen to this
[ __ ] that's stupid and also so much
had happened and so much there were we
just want to get there so I tried a
version where he comes up and says hey
the phone rings and he goes never mind
and for some reason that got all of the
emotional that got far more people
watched that and they cried
and uh so yeah sometimes you just it's
what you don't a lot of times in movies
is what you you take anything you can
take out and leave it blank
a space where like this almost feels
like there's a mistake there's a weird
emotional reaction to that yeah I got
that the dad was like oh here's a woman
that cares about you so you need to take
this yes and he and that was him he did
that I mean the line is that's your wife
but he pointed at it and he made a thing
of it that's your wife you should take
that
yeah there's a lot of meaning in that
moment the thing I love about making
movies is is that you I don't really
know what the movie's about the story
just kind of comes to you and you sort
of it's almost like you're taking
dictation like I guess this is what
happens it just makes you you try to
write it as involuntarily as possible
and then as you make the movie you get
to sit there and watch the [ __ ] happen
you go [ __ ] this is what that means
that's why that have like you start to
learn about it as you make it yeah and
sometimes actors get lost and you can as
a director help them by talking about
that I think this is what he's trying I
don't know
and sometimes they know when you don't
it's [ __ ] it's like it's like if you
could do it with life like deconstruct
life and have all the dialogues between
your family members in front of him and
just watch as a spectator yeah
but I never feel like it's like about
controlling it or saying you got to do
this again you just learn you learn
through it you know yeah and when it's
comedy when it's funny and it's
you know it was yeah I found it
fascinating I love the the sponsor
calling and [ __ ] with the dumb lines
he's [ __ ] like oh this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] but it's the [ __ ] you need to
hear that keeps you in a [ __ ]
comfortable repetition of like okay this
is what I do every day this is how I get
through the day that's how I get through
it yeah yeah and Joe really wanted it
was important to him because I'm not an
AAA guy but
um he it was important to him to have it
not be a typical AAA movie where
somebody always falls off the wagon yeah
and get back on and it's very Earnest
and it's all just how terrific A.A is he
wanted to show that it's a pain in the
ass when a guy talks too long and then
somebody always complains like I
wouldn't shut up yeah and uh and that
when you get it spawn C it's awkward
it's [ __ ] it's not it's not lovely
it's like what do I gonna say to this
[ __ ] guy I don't even like this guy
dude there's a guy that I met years ago
at a meeting I don't even know who he is
he calls me [ __ ] once every week dude
and I thought I have no idea what he
looks like I have no [ __ ] clue dude
and he drives me absolutely insane but
every now and then I'm in a low moment
or whatever yeah and I'll [ __ ] you
know and half the time I take the call
what's going on yeah you know I don't
know it's interesting that whole world's
interesting
um what was it like so just real quick
you you worked with Joe Rogan when you
were young right when you were younger
did you guys both start in Boston yeah
we both started in Boston at the clubs
and he was like a handsomest guy yes he
was yeah I mean Joe's still a handsome
guy right I loved her and uh but I was
there any like because now if you're
like a handsome comedian people are like
oh [ __ ] this guy right here you can't
have it all no handsome doesn't help you
on stage yeah was it like where people
like that against like whenever he was
starting out well I remember when he I
was I started maybe a couple years
before him so I was starting to feel
like you know established or in that
little Boston scene
and then this guy he started with guys
like Greg Fitzsimmons and him yeah
they're still really close yeah and
there was a few other guys Robbie Prince
he might have been after
but these guys were like new they're the
First new guys I was aware of oh yeah
because I I had been a new guy for a
couple years
and so now these were new guys to me so
I was probably threatened by them
whatever but I do remember feeling like
Greg Greg was a you know he's an Irish
kind of like he's not as handsome no
yeah but not back then he was more
handsome yeah Greg's like a book he
[ __ ] like cousin yeah
exactly yes but uh Joe
it wasn't just his looks it was just he
had this confidence yeah and he's from I
we grew up in the same town I'm from
Newton Massachusetts he grew up there
too okay so I went to Newton North High
School he went to Newton South both
Public Schools but his was kind of
fancier they're like kind of richer
because I kind of thought of him as this
like Newton South
he was so tanned oh he looked the dude
looks great yeah and he was just like
dude like he didn't he didn't talk like
a comic
he talked about [ __ ] chicks and he
talked about being getting being hot and
getting laid or whatever and he and uh I
could see that he had a power on stage
but yeah I was threatened by him because
he was like a good looking guy a couple
years younger than me started after me
yeah who was getting some attention yeah
and uh so on stage I would be like what
is what's what's for this guy but that's
I mean Nick depaolo started a year after
me and we didn't like we were like
Rivals we didn't like each other at all
because we were both like new guys were
getting big laughs but then we were very
good friends yeah he's in the movie yeah
yes the funny I didn't even know that
that was him until the end I'm talking
to him yeah oh he looks very different
yeah he looks different
yeah somebody's like that singing now I
was like oh my God that's where I knew
him from yeah but uh man but Joe was and
uh but then I got to know him and I
really liked him and he was he was a
fascinating guy he was a Taekwondo like
black belt Champion he's like a champion
and uh
we talked we would talk about
fighting and life and stuff and I just
liked him as soon as I got to know him I
liked him and then I started watching
like any comedian you first see when you
go well it was what's so great about him
I mean when you're younger but when I
watched him then I go then I started to
really respect what he and most of what
he got good after I knew him because he
was still just new and raw and he was I
felt he was killing because he was there
is a level where you can the girls like
you on stage he was also [ __ ] every
weight every hot waiter he was getting
all the places how are you supposed to
like I like that but but personally
one-on-one I really did like him a lot
and then I started [ __ ] him but I
would have [ __ ] stood by him watch it
put your hand on the back yeah a little
little of this with Joe Rogan not bad
yeah but he was also
interesting as a guy and not typical
some guys who are handsome are trapped
by that you know
but he was an interesting dude and then
when he went on and and I'd hear his
stand up I I was like that's he's
working and he's good and I liked his
stand up
um and then he we had kind of a
Crossroads thing because he did that
thing with Carlos Mencia where he outed
him first oh yeah which however you feel
about that but that it was his he was
very he's adamantly about it and then
his agency Gersh told him if you don't
dump uh if you don't stop if you don't
apologize to Carlos
will dump you and that was my agency was
Gersh
and so he let them go and I heard that
and I was like that's crazy and I called
him and we didn't we hadn't talked in a
long time but I contacted him to say I
need to hear from you if that's a true
story and he said 100 wow they called me
and they said apologize or you're out of
the agency and that's all I needed to
hear I called them and I said you're not
my agents anymore what if I have an
argument with another comedian what are
you [ __ ] nuts yeah you can't do that
so I dumped them and then I got started
to know that side of Joe
that's like he believes what he believes
and he goes by it whether it's going to
hurt him or not
and I've always known him that way we
just would run our friendship has been
like running into each other in the
parking lot of this Comedy Store and
talking for a couple hours about life
and that's most of comedians yeah yeah
yeah people always ask what he's like
he's one of the most generally curious
guys I ever met yeah like he has like
any of that he just retains information
so well and people are always like we a
lot of you podcaster guys you guys suck
Rogan's dick you know that kind of stuff
you like him number one yeah and he's
good at it yeah it's like you want to
look you like you want to learn and look
up and like not emulate but you there's
a certain homage especially in a space
where guys like him and Marin and some
other guys you know but even you even
putting yourself on your website for
five dollars early on that was like
it was a Pioneers type of move a lot of
people were like yes guys that's crazy
yeah I was kind of new at the time I
mean it only works if you have your fans
already it doesn't help you get fans
right so a lot of I know some Comics did
it after me and they're like I'm gonna
do it but they didn't I I I it worked
for me because I was swelling I was
starting to get [ __ ] ton of like you had
a fan base yeah yeah but it doesn't help
you gather it's the thing and I I do
think that to some degree because I
don't have that allure in the media
attention as much it's get sometimes it
feels like it's getting it's just
wearing down a little bit you know
because it's just me and them right so
getting new people it doesn't come as
easily but I that's such an easy thing
to accept also I'm 55 I mean how many
more years am I going to be alive you
know let alone working yeah it's not
like I needed to just keep piling up and
getting bigger but um and you've got I
mean you've got I mean you got you've
gotten it I mean
you've gotten to be that big yeah
exactly you don't need to stay big
that's crazy and it's all kind of high
it's all this mythological type of thing
it's all this you know it's like that
whole business it all kind of is works
together it's like the age and his
friends with the Press guy it's all this
yeah and once somebody gets big then
then there's this crazy Rush towards
them because they're big and people just
go well I guess I like him too but that
never lasts and it's like going to space
you just got to be able to come you just
come back down and you land in a lake
and you land in a lake and then you're
left with whatever amount of fans you
have and that's your cruising altitude
yeah and that because everybody has that
trajectory and then you don't hear about
them but they're out there touring you
know Pearl Jam isn't at the Grammys
anymore right but they're [ __ ]
selling out whatever size place they
want to they're just in the you know
they're you get your orbit
um if you're lucky and not everybody
gets to have that yeah I mean Motley
Crue is one of the like brought in one
of the most monies last year I read
somewhere right which blew my mind yeah
nobody's talking about Motley Crue but
the fact that they're yeah they stay
busy there's a lot of there's a lot of
work out there but also I don't I think
I mean I don't know that's why the show
at the Garden that I'm doing
that I'm live streaming and it's all
sold yeah so the show I think we've got
about 500 tickets left but it's like 19
000 right but also you can buy you can
you can purchase it online and we'll put
the link in this video and we'll also
make sure that um we run an ad that week
if we don't if this doesn't come out
that week we'll run an ad that week for
the show oh thanks man yeah for sure
it's exciting but that to me is like a
way to like say a kind of a one more and
goodbye to that to that level
um uh and then I'm probably gonna take a
break for a while I think I might take a
year or more off and not perform for a
while I want to feel what life feels
like with that I haven't done that since
I was
18 I haven't stopped
so your show was one of the first shows
I'd seen since the maybe the first time
that I'd seen comedy that I went to and
stood in line and went to see yeah wow
that's yeah that's that's rare I don't
haven't done that in a long time myself
so Norm MacDonald's last guy I went
bought a ticket and sat and watched
um a few years ago it was great yeah
great great great and actually I just
remember I lied to you I saw Bob Newhart
oh yeah where'd you see him I saw him in
Chicago at the Chicago theater no [ __ ]
yeah and he was telling jokes and I was
like oh these are just jokes that he
[ __ ] read off the internet right no
but then I realized no no the jokes were
just such old baked in the society jokes
he had [ __ ] created them oh yeah of
course
of course they're all him yeah I'm like
wow these are just shitty internet jokes
and then I'm like oh he [ __ ] made
these up I met him once he was with Don
Rickles wow and uh they were at a
restaurant I was out and the two of them
and their wives were sitting and and uh
one of their wives or somebody came from
that table over to me and said Don would
like to say hi to you so I walked back
to the table and Don had his back to me
and he goes he's not coming over here is
he that [ __ ] piece of shit's not
coming over oh hi like he did a thing
and he just starts [ __ ] on me he's
like look you what are you what is this
you fat how [ __ ] old are you what are
you what good are you and I'm just glow
you know I just feel great and Bob's got
this huge beaming smile on his face
because he can see that his friend is
happy yeah and uh and I just stood there
and took a beating
for about 10 minutes and just you know
and said hello to the ladies and I
honored them you know Bob you're the
best Don you're the best and then Don
kind of took my he was very old like a
few months before he died I think wow he
took my shirt and pulled me down and he
said
don't let him forget me
please don't let people forget me who I
was did he really yep and he said it
really earnestly
wow isn't that something yeah
anyway nobody remembers who that is
we know yeah we know yep but that's yeah
it's wow that it all goes back into the
sauce man
it all goes back into the [ __ ] nuts
yeah whatever you're able to do
everybody's gonna forget all of it
all of it
I feel like we got to keep a little of
it
that's why I don't want to be cremated
when I see people that are getting
cremated I'm like you're a [ __ ]
because what if even a little bit of you
is alive you know huh yeah
you think that body might still be alive
you have eight cells left you have
billions of [ __ ] cells you don't get
[ __ ] 30 cells left and they're like
do you think that's gonna be you like
that's you I think it has time
recollection it has some memory of yeah
I think it holds why does it need to
stay alive you feel like it needs to as
long as you can hang in there yeah and
then you're like oh [ __ ] I'm getting
grilled like this is the absolute worst
so you're gonna get buried I think
buried straight into the ground you know
actually you know I just want to get
shot out of a cannon in like a
schoolyard and the first kid to touch my
dick [ __ ] wins wins all my money
that's not bad that's not bad that's not
bad there's places you can get buried
right in the ground without a box like
Maine I think you can throw a body in
the ground anywhere you want in the
state of Maine yeah there's nothing any
good I want to believe with a few more
chicks around though I think yeah oh
yeah
I don't really have any wishes for after
really yeah I I I want to leave that up
to my kids because they'll be the ones
that have to experience it what do you
think they'll do I don't know it depends
on how I do yeah yeah that's up to me
you know it's all up to us uh Louis CK
anything else guys you wanted to ask
that
um yeah last question uh I saw Fourth of
July in theaters and a lot of the people
were I feel like their reaction is how
hyped they were to see comedians in a
movie like actual comics in a movie yeah
what other Comics do you want to see in
movies
oh [ __ ] uh
you'd have a project or something I
wrote a movie with a friend of mine that
I'm gonna try to make next year
but it's really twisted weird movie and
it's probably going to be too expensive
so I may not get to make it but I'm
gonna try
I don't know if there's any comedians in
that one I like me you know who I always
thought would be a good dramatic actor
his Tim Heidecker you know who he is Tim
and Eric yeah
Tim heidecker's I saw him I was in
London
is how crazy my life was I had just made
a movie which never came out and I went
to London because I did the music at
Abbey Road Studios I was just I was like
I was telling him before I was [ __ ]
money then I was just and now it's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] right at the time I [ __ ] money
and I had made this movie and I had a
composer because I wanted to do his
orchestrals score yeah and he said okay
we can get a great Orchestra a really
great Orchestra for like 150 000 bucks
they'll be the best in any any movie
you've watched recently would have this
Orchestra or we can go to Abbey Road and
get the best players in Europe like the
best players of at every instrument for
300 000.
and I was like it's just a check bro
[ __ ] yeah let's get go let's go and I
went to Abbey Road and we recorded music
with a full Orchestra it's the [ __ ]
sickest thing it's it's like I was a
Coke addict it was a really crazy thing
to do yeah but anyway while I was there
Tim Heidecker was playing at the Soho
theater so I just went to watch him and
he was wearing this uh leather jacket
that was uh you know like a leather
blazer yeah and he had his hair slicked
back and he's just he's a very you don't
know where he's coming from guy yeah
just being really weird and sarcastic
but seeming real at the same time and I
was riveted by his show he got a few
laughs he wasn't he's not like a killer
comic because he doesn't try to be but I
thought that guy would be a really I'd
like to see him kill somebody in a movie
I'd like to see him yeah he's got a Gacy
Vibe Gacy yeah a little bit I think he
could do some I could think he could
scare the [ __ ] out of somebody in a
movie yeah that's when I look at
comedians I look at that there's guys
that you you go that guy's gonna get me
laughs I won't make a movie without
Bobby Kelly probably ever he's just the
greatest face in a movie Nick de Paul
these are just the guys who I just go
like he's got to be in it yeah
um Bobby's a sweet guy a Laura
keitlinger who I mentioned before I'd
love I'd love to see her in a movie
someday still she's just she was in a
sitcom I did for one season and she was
great
um there's a lot a lot of people out
there hey you captured I mean you just
yeah I mean I just yeah I love Fourth of
July and you guys can all check it out
you can subscribe uh you can January
28th is the special yeah it's 25 bucks
to watch it live or you get to watch for
10 days and it's what I saw you last
night yeah same show wow yeah [ __ ] we
might we might buy it I hope so well you
can have it for free we'll buy it we'll
buy it man
um Louie thank you so much man thanks
for having me yeah it's really fun that
was really fun yeah me too man it's
interesting I don't like podcasts
they're too serious
and everybody talks about you know their
view on life yeah and everybody talks
about the same [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just
the same four subjects we've been
talking about since like 2012 and it's
really boring I feel like we talked
about those the comedy jerking off yeah
a little bit but those are that's real
life we talked about real life yeah
enjoy the hell out of it oh thank you
man I did too man this was a real honor
and once again you're a hysterically
funny comic with Sweden I hope that you
focus on the stand-up I know this is
good but I hope that you stay on stage a
lot because if you've only been doing it
for 18 years you're not even there yet I
mean if that's how good you are now then
if you keep the stand up being number
one and when you get to about 22 years
or so
you're gonna be uh Unstoppable
so I hope you do thank you man yeah I
hope to yeah I think that's where I'm at
right now figuring out kind of how to
evolve you know good um thank you very
much Louis CK now I'm just floating on
the breeze
[Music]
that ground I'll share this piece of my
life
[Music]
gonna take